[Music]
[Music]
it's the Hyatt Regency in Yekaterinburg
host to the 2020 candidates tournament
the first major major major event of the
year for this chess players as they are
determining who will face Magnus Carlsen
later on this year for the title open
world chess champion
I am Grandmaster Alejandra Maris here
with legendary GM Yassir Sarah won that
state hello everyone and welcome to
chest today in chess as we pick up the
round one of the candidates and the
players have just brought some
incredible preparation to their games as
we get into our show
it's absolutely explosive let's take a
look at who is participating in this
event first of all we are headlined by
our very own familiar corona the first
seed of the event by a solid margin
after his impressive victory in Vikings
a second rating favorably Diggler in
only to 2800 of the tournament followed
by the two Russians Alexandra Christian
Yamanashi followed by max Eva allograft
very controversial this way of getting
into the tournament but he's there the
Frenchman finally getting his shot into
the candidates he will be followed by
aya nice giri Wang Howell will be the
seventh seed and of course it'll be
another controversial pick kerala alex
anko asked a wild card of the event
certainly the lowest rated player if you
see considerably lower rated than his
opponents but he's young he's prepared
and he will definitely be the wild card
of the event let's move on to the format
it's a double round-robin 14 rounds of
chess a long event by today's standards
and also a long time control if you're a
classical fan this is your event 100
minutes for the first 40 moves 50
minutes for the next 20 that means that
Adam before you get another 50 and I
move 60 you get another 15
controls that indeed is a classical time
control so long and 500,000 euros per
prize for not bad it's different from
all the candidates they won't be able to
offer each other drawers before blocks
for years so they will have no short
drawers in this event by agreement of
course three move repetition still
allowed but that only the exception
let's take a look at this schedule of
course we have round one underway right
now and get used to this three rounds of
chess at a break date that will be the
setup of the event it's a very long
tournament therefore the players will
get plenty of rest days you can see that
green bars right there
and well it's a long event yes we are
already underway so let's go to
grandmaster Maurice Ashley that has some
action for us indeed there has been
tremendous action so far in this event
what a tournament the world watching
this incredible event with eight players
trying to figure out who's going to play
the world champion Magnus Carlsen and
we've got some hungry players two of
them here a nice giri from holland and
yon Anupam Miyaichi
from russia and this game absolutely a
wild one as neppo after the move b3
played Bishop to b4 wandering after beat
takes why could he play rook to a3 this
piece looks like it's going to come
under heavy fire and it did after the
move Queen a5 this Knight is under
pressure
a5 might happen in any moment to trap
the bishop how come Bishop e2 and then
an exchange sacrifice with rook takes c3
King to f1 and after before defending
the rook g5 trying to open up this King
side a smashing move indeed and after a
5 he did capture back the exchange and
takes on f6 and now the move Queen b1
hitting this square on 87 as well
there's a passed pawn in White's
position absolutely crazy chess and
another game that started off wild was
this one between Maxima Sheila Gras the
Frenchman who barely got into this
tournament had the last minute versus a
favorite in this event Fabiano Caruana
and after Queen c7 z51 a smashing Knight
takes on f7 what a wild move you would
think this one would be maybe a knockout
punch the cool calm Eve
or in reply saying do your worst I'm not
afraid of any of your disco checks 96
check King to h8 9 take 77 the game calm
down considerably and if we jump down to
this point the move c5 a little bit
unexpected a reasonable move maybe not
the most cantankerous fighting move
because here rook takes the one Bishop
c5 Queen to f2 and it looks like them
potentially could be some trades will he
or won't he be sure takes on e3 or
Bishop d6 in fact he has played the move
Bishop to d6 keeping the tension alive
so still a lot to play for in this one
and of course might be on a Caruana
wants to win this event he is first of
all the number one seed significantly so
rated at 28 42 and the only player in
this event who has played for a world
championship title having famously tied
Magnus Carlsen and 12 games of classic
oh and only losing in the tiebreak in
the last World Championship this
number-two ranked player on the planet
we know he can be a dominant player we
saw him do that fabulous results back in
the Sinquefield Cup where he won seven
games in a row to start the event when
the best performances in tournament
history and he's for him it seems to be
back as he did just win Tata Steel ahead
of Magnus Carlsen in January he is
absolutely dangerous and could be indeed
the dominant favorite in the field a lot
of Chinese players will say well oh wait
a min we got big Lauren on and let's not
get out of hand on the other hand his
opponent Maxine ba Sheila grab he is
clearly one of the best in the world
certainly deserving to be in such an
event but he did not qualify through the
natural methods only getting here
because Timur Yaba of Azerbaijan decided
he did not want to play due to all the
health concerns that is bothering the
world at at the moment but he is
certainly a deserving a player he has
been in the world's elite for the
longest time he has won his big events
he won the fifth Sinquefield Cup ahead
of all the best of the best in the world
so he is absolutely a player that can
show he can
be here he deserves to be here in terms
of strength level will he prove it as
he's gotten this opportunity to be able
to play the lifetime score well not so
bad again Mike seems showing that he can
play against the world's elite
five wins six losses and 22 draws
practically a statistical dead heat as
far as these two are concern and this
game is showing it as a very close game
at the moment exciting games to start
the tournament absolutely that's what we
would expect from a candidates Thank You
Maurice for me Alejandro really feels
like for this round especially
preparation is dominating the opening
play here and it will be something you
will have to see for the following
rounds before we get into that let's
take a look at how they got into this
tournament it's all of the candidates
all eight of them of course
back when favi lost the magnus carlsen
in 2018 we already knew he was seated
into the next candidates the top two
finishes of the chest World Cup 2019
immediately qualified those four Teemu
raja baath as the winner and ding lien
asked the runner-up of course we've
mentioned tomorrow Java has dropped out
of the tournament
and has been replaced by Maxine Beshear
legrasse top finishers from the grand
Swiss sorry the top finisher that is
Wang Hao the top two finishes from the
Grand Prix series of the two Russians
younger from yashi and Alexandra pretty
sure the highest average field rating of
the previous year onigiri onigiri and
the wild-card chosen by the organizer
with the caveat that it couldn't just be
any wild card they wanted they have to
be somebody that was rated over 2,700 at
the time of invitation and had to finish
just outside of the winner's circle in
one of these tournaments either the
grand swiss or the grand prix and there
was only two people that would fulfill
those requirements might see Michela
graph or Russian - real alex ago and of
course the Russian Federation when with
Kirill the parents for today we've
already talked about Maxine but Sherlock
up against Fabiano Khurana
meanwhile Alexander Chris Kirk is facing
off against Camilla Alex anko jinglin
against Wang Hao an onigiri against the
end
this pairings that you see are not
completely random they are randomized
but they also ensure that compatriots do
not face off in their last rounds
exactly you just want to avoid any kind
of situation where there could be any
question of collusion or compromised
play so that's very very nice and again
what what a way to start the tournament
it's very exciting
Maurice I agree and one of the great
things about events with disparities in
ratings we see number one Fabiano
Caruana twenty eight forty forty two was
it and then you have at the bottom a
player who is not even twenty seven
hundred we could go way back in time to
remember a time when a player is in the
candidates the world's elite trying to
decide who plays against the world
champion and they're below 2,700 that
mean that's just seeming seemingly
unimaginable you really have to go back
decades in order to find that in this
kind of format but when that happens you
find exciting chess abounds it's sort of
like the Tata Steel tournament I
mentioned one of the great things about
Tata Steel is there's always a mix of
the elite and lower rated players you
live in the country yes sir
you've seen this tournament up close and
you know it's always exciting people
going after points they see they say you
are lower rated player they're thinking
you're a point baby I'm not today you
can't be the guy I let off the hook we
might draw other players as you see
happen in the super elite tournaments
when the best of the best way each other
but when you have lower rated players I
gotta get some points and that seems to
bring bring out the feeding frenzy in
the top players although that doesn't
always turn out well for them remember
Jordan Forrest this year one of the
lowest he had fantastic event he just
went on a roll beating a lot of the top
players proving that it's not easy to
beat any of these players even if
they're not quite 2,700 and let's be
fair to Carroll when he was invited he
actually was a 27 all right he slipped
as you had mentioned he just lived there
were two players in the candidates that
were actually in Gibraltar playing in
that event both Maxime and Carol were
participating okay to be honest I was
also playing and they do
like there were candidates they were
just in the middle of the pack okay they
were they didn't distinguish them sorry
3 1 Paulo salsa playing but he was near
the top the entire event indeed but
Maxime you know he made a few draws
people saw him as a target to make quick
draw by preparation he wasn't really
able to get out of it of course opens
are a very different beast then a
candidate's in a closed event ask you
about it you mentioned preparation yes
separation being so key going into this
yes and if you look at the Instagram of
onigiri preparation preparation
preparation I mean every day the guy was
training his secret seconds Maxime he
didn't know he was playing right he took
a vacation to New York he was feeling
with this friends right you know how is
this gonna affect the tournament except
these guys are so professional that's
what they're doing you know 12 months of
the year I mean is preparation I mean he
got the ticket just like weeks ago and
he said I'm in I mean I may not have
been preparing as long as these guys but
I'll definitely play I just wanted to
say also in the top of Steel we
mentioned seven out of seven the
Sinquefield Cup but look what fabbi did
in that tournament of course it's nav
out of seven at the end which was an
amazing it was brilliant
it was just I mean a fabbi at his best
Maurice you got fab YZ game on your
board yes and just make it that point
about mvl Alejandra you just said the
thing is yes he wasn't able to prepare
specifically for these players but these
players weren't able to prepare
specifically for him either he did
imagine all the work these players put
in to prepare for Timur and then found
out wait
we're not playing against him how much
work they dug into his repertoire all
those hours and days of work to dig into
playing against this one player and it's
almost such a pity because Maxime is so
predictable if you had to say one of
many weaknesses of these players Maxime
specifically that would be his
preparation is so so now
night or night and II for exactly by the
way helps him if you think about it also
because he comes in saying that's what I
play I'm always boning up always keeping
my positions as clean as possible so I
got my latest novelties ready for you
guys you weren't preparing against me at
all and all of a sudden you got to look
back and all the preparation to find
what he does again to say whoa K has he
discovered anything new in this in this
his favorite stuff so there it's it's a
I think it's a two-way street here
whether or not the preparation is going
to matter but to me what's gonna really
count is form and hunger I mean that's
what it comes down to in the end its
form how well you're playing and hunger
you can get all the preparation you want
all the decent positions you want but if
you're not informed it doesn't matter
and if you're not as hungry and
desperate to win it doesn't matter and
by the way let's point out the favorite
rating favorite to win this tournament
has not won did not win the last time
did not win the time before that did not
win the time before that you had to go
back to Magnus Carlsen who barely hung
on and one is eart tournament in 2013 in
London where he tied Kramnik and won
only on a tie break so just because
you're the reigning favourite I know
we're gonna be picking our favorites
soon but just because you're a rating
favourite doesn't mean doesn't mean that
you're going to win the tournament well
this is going to be a biased comment
very clear let's go straight Alex anko's
board up yep take me through it well
indeed this started out as in English
and Alexander grishnack the rating
favorite and by the way Greek has had
such a storied career I mean this is his
time if he doesn't perform at this
candidates he's not going to become a
challenger if you go back 20 years the
guy's been spoken about as a potential
challenger for 20 years I mean he's
really really that good he's been in the
elite for that long but in these
candidates tournaments he has not
distinguished himself now we have a
pretty
normal-looking position I do like white
space I do like that White's the one who
can occupy the center with d4 I like how
you view this because you said white
space and you might be thinking
Whitehouse pause on c3 and d3 they're a
little bit backwards right but you kind
of see the potential of the position
right you see it coming to d4 you see
them coming to e4 if his bishop and
ambush is going to have this nice
diagonal to remove like d4 I'm I'm
anticipating that you don't really want
to take if you take then you open up
this bishop I'm thinking that black is
going to just step back and say okay go
ahead and occupy as much space as you
want you know I've got some ideas here
there's some potential on the light
squares on the Kings side can imagine a
bishop posting up so it feels a little
bit of an advantage but black solid yes
sir we haven't done commentary together
in a while we have our fights in a bit
but I got to say the very first game you
decide to look at is in English three
out of four on the English there are
three English openings today on fire I
mean we dug into a little bit already
but I'd like to hear your insights on
this one which agreed was in English as
well let me just start off okay but not
the quiet sleepy fest you just look at
this one here could we were a mesmerized
geyser by this position the variations
Alejandro and I just walked in you said
Murray did you see what's happening and
now I know you started showing me some
lines let's dig into those lines because
this was chaos to start this game indeed
well let's take a look let's pull out
the Napalm naqshi game he's playing with
a black piece against onigiri
and this preparation it's just so deep
it was spectacular right let's just be
quite honest right this is a well known
position see for Roxy one if we go to
the position before rook c1 this
position has been reached before
top level chess okay and rusi one here
is the novelty okay what was the pre
standard before what I want to say that
was Queen b3 yeah which which sure looks
like the most natural move by balling
this pawn is at 64 if the guy doesn't
watch out hello hello
so rook c1 was the new move and then
instantly the players seemed to just go
directly into this very sharp line
Alejandra and it was very clear a niche
game very well prepared but we never
know nepalese prepares it doesn't matter
if he knows the position or not that
will do that many many times and here
this move Bishop beef that looks like a
starting piece sacrifice that you have
to calculate very very deeply absolutely
he did spend some time on it so he was
not buying it silly but we don't know if
he was remembering his preparation or he
was just calculating at this point
Bishop e5 and f6 and it's like the both
players are walking this very very
narrow line I mean you just cannot
deviate any deviations it'll cost you
the game right away Bishop d4 Queen a5
this moment was very important because
the natural move is the guard of the
night right yes right I mean easy-peasy
what if I just play something like Queen
d2 but no can do because II 5 is coming
in the middle of the board is just
trapped and the night is still pinned so
you had to just throw this piece away
but then you don't throw the piece away
you make an extreme sacrifice is
absolutely amazing you valued this
Bishop so highly this by the fact that
you kind of constantly word of the move
e5 actually winning the bishop right
this Bishop needs to stay alive because
it's the cornerstone of whites attack
and we'll get into that in just a second
I want to point out something very
important a lot of people say chess has
been killed by the computers mm-hmm but
if you see this engine evaluation it was
just black black black it was - OH -
warm wonderful for black and a lot of
the job that ii have right now is
figuring out where the computers just
lying to you it's just wrong it's just
wrong and this is one of those cases
where you go into this position
route c1 hadn't been discovered because
it's just better for but according to me
and according to the engine but if you
go deeper
the engine just changes its mind you
remind me you remind me Alejandro of
that great game that Fabi beat Nakamura
in London yes where he sacrificed his
Queen for two pieces in the night and
and afterwards
Fabi said yeah the engine said that this
position was equal Nakamura preparation
said yeah I studied this was supposed to
be equal but Fabi understood with his
second wisdom and maybe with you as well
I don't know if you were working on him
in this position at the time working
with him but he said no no way this is
right why it must be better despite
being a queen down for two pieces I
believe you had maybe a pawn as well he
said no this is a boss position for
white and he was absolutely right the
engines were dead wrong and that's one
of the great things about this modern
age of being able to work with engines
and say yeah the engine says this but
what does the human think and comparing
in each situation and seeing the human
out think the engine and this is one of
those where you see you might start
counting hey I'm up in exchange right I
got material
no but that Bishop on d4 baby you better
watch out and let's continue how did the
game progress because we have this
position on the board
Brooke takes c3 of course there's and
discovers with the rook so you have to
move out of the way King f1 this nice
quiet movie the white is basically
saying my rook on h1 is so valuable I
don't want a castle my king was gonna is
going to be parked very nicely on in g2
and of course this rook is hanging and
in the meantime g4 g5 starts to present
black real issues before you yeah this
wasn't the move that we really as we
came into the studio that we really
looked at I mean for for definitely for
Maurice and I the position was unique
new and we were looking at takes and
then you were showing us some incredible
lines that started with g5 l g5 would
have been the follow-up had nipple me
actually taking on c4 and I was looking
at things like for example castling in
this position and the brilliant idea of
king G - yeah
immediately threatening route takes h7
let's just put some dumb move into
position to explain what's going on it's
not so dumb Bishop d7
yeah take on h7 with the rook without
even wasting time take you next time
with the King what else can you do
you're getting made it Queen h1 check
you can't step up because you do get
made it after Queen h5 King f5 and
something like g6 must be made at some
point yes they can do mate you got to
play the f3 made play with a smile ok so
yeah after yes h1 but after g6 it
doesn't matter how much much earlier
down this King is animating net it's not
gonna get out the Tongass on t4 just
toast yeah just completely dead yep so
this was certainly gurus preparation
Nepal me I just sidestepped it because
after before this was the first time
that the Dutch player took a long thing
uh-huh
he paused now and he chose d5 before he
played the thing about this move that's
really important to note is that the d5
pawn is protected by the Queen great
before when when you were to hitting
that was like if you backup one movie
you play let's say play e5 right now
alright the movie 5 bishop takes on c3
and then the d5 pawn is hanging
immediate I think Queen Queen takes we
think is really far stronger actually
Queen takes hitting the b5 pawn would
check stopping you from castling some
rookie 7 threats are in the position
right here
well everything's gonna drop so this
move before this is the logic of it in
Nepos mine is my Queens guarding now
laterally so all that is perfectly safe
you can have your exchange back but
you're not going to be better in this
position so this is where Anish decided
okay I'm gonna go for my stuff that I
was always going for with the g5 flesh
exactly doesn't see a big difference
between the positions with before taking
on c4 he says g5 is necessary I need to
open my bishop I need to get to your
king
'if I've played a very practical
decision gives up the material right but
says I'm kind of consolidating my
position and let's see after Queen b1
hitting the h7 hold on let's back up
because right here was a critical line C
takes on d5 who were looking
as well absolutely another possibility
right this was a huge option get your
pawns going up the board but there is
the counter shot that he got to watch
out for Queen takes a to wear black
suddenly has two connected passers on
the board yes his kick is weak yes white
has a pass deep on okay but I got two
connected passers don't let this game
settle down or else I might be the one
arguing for something and we were
looking at King g2 Bishop f5 and the
determination was was that blacks okay I
made it look looks like you could be in
trouble but look like worked his way out
of this line and that's a that's a huge
line to note because that motivated him
to play the move Queen b1 precisely and
Queen B 1 in attacks h7 and it defends a
2 but there's one big elephant in the
room here that pawn on c3 exactly it
doesn't matter how many other pawns
white collects or white loses if that
final c3 actually becomes dangerous yeah
as you can imagine that if white just
was the executors threat with rook takes
h7 again that pawn on c3 is the elephant
in the room okay the difference of
course is blacks King is a bit
vulnerable and there is a bishop h5
check as well in the meanwhile Queen c7
looked like a very decent move to my my
eyes you just defend the pawn on h7
Mary's decent again in these kind of
positions but the move d4 was certainly
fascinating past pause one way let's get
it another way this move is absolutely
insane if you take on d4 now which may
not be called for takes takes and then
Brooke aged 7 then we do have this
possibility of trading and then rook
takes Queen takes and then Bishop f5 and
telling white boy you better not let my
King do a march all the way to B 2 as
you can tell you could chase that came
with some checks you could check a check
all day but that King is gonna start
running didn't Fabi win a game putting
his King on b2 Tata Steel
genius so that's what it's reflecting in
my mind right now so this kind of thing
he said okay I'm back in business
he could have played for the sharp d4
but he opted out and play the super
solid Queen c7 but it's a tough position
to be in because d4 yes I want to
connect my pawns but my king I think I
need to defend if I don't take on d4 in
that variation that you just gave
Maurice and I go does make that big
difference because the bishop can get to
f5 here right on the other hand my
structure is a bit more solid it means
that I have more diagonal protection
exactly b6 get the job done here maybe
I'm a little bit worried about the
organization of the of the King what
what is happening anybody with a queen
and a bishop I'm good I'm hoping for a
professional here for white that's what
it feels like as well for me so maybe a
missed opportunity here yeah actually I
just I just checked the engine because
this position is so chaotic and this
position right here it says King d8 yes
no not giving up this pawn you start
checking you're just gonna send it don't
let the king sit on be a knight
devastating nice protection and these
pawns look sexy boy get goes rolling
down the board so yeah
d4 could have been should have been
maybe but okay we can't live in
hypothetical where I we actually do live
I put that ago world when we analyze
chess that could have been a real chance
for that book let's remember it's yeah
c7 sorry I just still didn't see what
anything wrong with it if you take on d5
I want to play c2 no Queen c7 looks like
a very logical movement as well because
at this point there are so many options
and when you have an engine and it
throws out d4 you kind of tempted right
but if you look at this from a practical
point of view Queen c7 solidifies your
position difference h7 you need it put
the Queen behind your passport right and
protecting the pawn as it rumbles up the
board with again c2 and I'm thinking
that well
White's got some issues that he has to
Maurice you know I'd also say there
there's some game theory business in
chess right no absolute so the the issue
of what should I Plus should I play the
best move or should I play the best move
given the situation and you see your
opponent blitzing out moves prep prep
prep prep right or you you wasted some
more time or friend you thinking okay
what move do I play
that's not his number one move and also
doesn't lose me the game but looks like
a pretty reasonable move and I move like
queen C d-four might be like maybe the
engine said top choice c7 might be one
of those okay baby it's not the wildest
craziest choice that the guys still
ready to play prep prep prep against but
it's solid it makes a lot of sense it
keeps some of the pluses in the position
it eliminates real danger and so neppo
is one of those gamblers we know he's a
gambler
you seen him play so fast in sharp
positions that you think how could you
be playing as fast and he may not make
the perfect move but he'll make the move
that challenges his opponent to find the
right answers but I want to point
something out I think is very important
URI comes in and blitz his 19 mousse of
chess exactly he's currently down on
time yes that's what I'm talking about
that is when you create when you play
the weird move you have been prepared
for sometimes that plays a factor in it
works against you that you seem sober I
remember once I was playing it was a
world open I was playing on one board
and grandmaster Patrick wolf I was I
wasn't it was a long time ago I wasn't
an iamb yet no GM title nothing but I
learned something
Patrick wolf was playing against Albert
Chang this is like 88 guys okay so so
they're playing a game and I'm trying to
play my game and next to me
they're whipping out moves and Albert is
like just dropping moose and I can't
even concentrate on your board so they
play all these moves and hours like prep
prep prep prep and then they get finally
to that position where a different move
shows up
and Patrick why's everyone Albert slows
down five or six moves later he's
resigning
so later Patrick is a friend I went over
to him I said what happened he said oh
he didn't understand a position but a
player wins that's how it works right
that's the thing you can be as prepped
as you want but if something funny
happens it almost works against you
because you you're like whoops what am I
supposed to do about this
you haven't really thought deeply about
this position you're seeing it for the
first time and you start burning time on
the clock and it didn't help you
oddly paradoxically that you have
prepared so deeply and these games are
absolutely crucial when you think about
the candidate such a long tournament you
think you know a couple bad rounds you
can recover yes you can but
psychologically it's been historical
that if you start slowly in the
candidates it's very very difficult to
recover from it last time we had the
candidates Wesley started 0 out of 2 and
that was it right he did not recover he
did not want to play chess he did not
want to it was done yeah it was done the
tournament was ever really before it
even started yeah so and let's take a
look at the lifetime scores it's really
not a lot of games no considering the
strength of these players and how often
many of the other players have met each
other this is just a sample it's more or
less an empanada being so active for a
couple of years taking a little bit of a
break coming back into chest
but speaking of chess let's go to the
other guys because we have so much of
action major just just to jump just to
accelerate your point and agree with it
completely this format this 8 players
playing a tournament to decide who plays
into the world champion this is a old
and new it's like old wine in new
bottles because 2013 is when they
restarted this format from the normal
match formats they had back in the day
yeah so you know about this restore
matches were played and then the winners
came out of the match for example
Fischer he got in that way and certainly
did Karpov and all that classical stuff
even into the modern day but 2013 is
when we had this exact format 8 players
playing a double run
and going the winner going to play the
world champion you have to actually go
way back in time to the original format
the very first true candidates Budapest
1950 when this format was in place it
was a 10 player events also double
round-robin one by two players Bronstein
Abella Slav ski and they had to play a
match to decide who went on to play by
Vinick and then they kept this same
format five times right five times they
played it it was Budapest
then it was Zurich 1953 if you haven't
read Bronstein's book on this go out to
get it right now then it was Amsterdam
1956 and and then and won by Smith Slav
he actually won both of those and then
we jumped to 1959 we're tall played the
monster that was insane they Neoga
Slavia three cities in fact bled and
Zagreb and and Belgrade and tal who did
something sick like ten wins out of 12
games at one point in the tournament the
other two being draws just truly epic
performance by the young men who ended
up becoming world champion right after
that and then finally Curacao in 1962 so
he had those for those five and then
they went away from it because of the
charissa issues attention the collusion
that Fischer complained about coronary
complained that the Soviets were banding
together and drawing their games so they
went to match play and that lasted all
the way and then we got finally back so
he's over 62 to 2013 to return to this
format only one time the one time in
they - in those nine tournaments is not
being the tenth one time that a player
lose round one and win the tournament
you don't want to lose round one that's
the bottom line this is too critical
right out the gate and the one time
remarkably was tall's tournament back in
1959 so the start matters don't think
it's more sample size we're talking
about nine tournaments already you've
got to start off strong if you want to
win in the candidates you know I I'm by
the way that tall victory that you got
to remember Parker as the second
how goes +10 in that Street and he's
thinking I'm gonna turn even know
because Kara's is like those were those
were the heydays of real fighting chest
28 rounds
can you imagine guys we're doing
commentary for 28 rounds and some
quadruple round robins this is 14 rounds
what have we got going on in the MBL vs.
fabbi position alejandro give us your
insights because after c5 a move that
you actually like Maurice and I were
both of like hey this is an isolated
Queen pond let's play against it let's
buy Queen da that's play rock d8 no I
thought it made sense to simplify the
position a bit I'm always scared in this
kind of situations that the bishops
eventually grow in power this one b3
especially right especially imagine some
kind of endgame a6 this week's c6 this
week yeah so I'm trying to figure out a
way to simplify as black of course with
an engine you can think oh there's
actually ways of Keith and attention and
but this is a very forcing move it's a
forcing move and it can't be bad no
that's this is one of those moves of the
game theory moments right again which
one do you want to play do you want to
simplify out do you want to maintain
attention because I really didn't like
see if it felt wrong c5 it felt like
giving what your possibilities could be
as black you should be using your
Trump's along the e-file with rook e8
yeah so you were in pawn hunting of
course exactly well in fact you guys
came up with an amazing shot I went
Queen d8 because hey my spidey-sense was
tingling I saw the two pawns on pre you
guys says okay you can have that pond
and I took it and then after g4 you guys
came up with it no that wasn't mine with
other engines move for short and that
okay that's just too beautiful
you can't just let that sit there let
the fans understand why this move it's
so powerful well the problem is if you
take I've got rook takes f6 and it's
actually mate in a6
as for starters yep
Queen takes f6 jack quicker than six in
this line because you're not going to g8
you got a block and yeah 94 monster me
monster
absolutely monster so don't go pawn
hunting and that was when pardon me but
here's what I thought this is what I
thought were key eight though because he
plays c5 right is is more dynamic and I
understand the beauty of Rukia
I also understand why c5 it's very
tempting move right I mean at this point
without an engine you're kind of thing I
don't know if I'm equal but c5 I can't
be worse I eliminate a couple of my
weaknesses I think it's a decent move I
totally understand that Rukia also has
its attraction but they're both good and
they're somewhat your mindset again what
that's why I put again people talk about
the best move hmm we're not always
looking for the best move we're looking
for the move of the moments yeah and
also the one that fits our style I mean
and it clearly Bishop takes e5 o or
disposition and actually I was that was
the other thing it wasn't that fabbi
actually had to recapture it once on c5
that kind of blew me away as well
because we were actually studying 96
it's a computer move okay it threatens
Knight d4 you can see that there's a
fork the bishops not actually defending
this because the Queen on e2 is
certainly hanging and there's also ideas
of taking the opponent 85% of the pawn
on c5 which is a tempo it's a mess
because you also kind of think if white
side steps this fork right do I really
want to stick by night on the edge of
the board and take that pawn is that in
the past one right doesn't feel logical
exactly exactly
no Bishop takes e5 definitely
recapturing the pawn and again it's
something that fabbi does so very well
it calculates deeply and he foresaw that
after Queen f2 this is a key moment this
is actually a very very key
and a lot of people would be tempted to
simply capture the bishop on e3 and say
hey I've got rid of the two bishop it's
our understanding that when you have two
bishops and you don't that you try to
eliminate those two bishops you want to
leave your opponent with the nine and
the bishop against your two knights
that's that that is the usual way that
you play this kind of situations but
fiving looks at the position says
patient e6 give me those dark squares I
don't care about your pair of Bishops
before now your king is gonna feel
vulnerable as long as my dark square
bishop is alive exactly and i thought
that was a really key insight that was
for me an amazing move because I thought
this ship takes III nine out of ten
grandmasters I think that's an automatic
move get rid of the two bishops and of
course before we catch up with the
players let me remind the viewers that
you are able to participate in the
conversation no really do so we have a
phone line open for you guys call us at
three one four three six one five four
six five and well we'll be here to
answer all of your questions regarding
the candidates and everything that
surrounds it and hundred who's doing now
social media or its international master
air gross and if you want to get him on
Twitter he'll be happy to answer your
questions as well right so this is an
interactive show we'll be happy to
answer all kinds of questions and
concerns but meanwhile yeah sir we have
so many more games that we haven't
looked at exactly we gotta go to I just
wanted to catch up with these guys so 93
Queen e2 and 93 of course came with a
temper against Queen Knight to c5
hitting the bishop on b3 and just a
quick what's your judgment position to
me if I had to evaluate it immediately I
would say it's about equal but it
depends on the following the dynamic
possibilities of the Knights in the next
couple of moves because if white
stabilizes the pair of bishops in an
open position you should be better than
the two knights exact the question is
what can I do with my nights in the next
couple of moves that will actually harm
white not just put a little bit like
harm light you know you you you read of
it
you capture upon you do something
concrete right and this is what I want
to find out find out because obviously
well it's gonna retreat the bishop I
don't know if CT were a - he did already
see God or a - a - a - a - okay
and now now comes a key question right
you are Fabi you have two knives there
are some ideas with Queen e5 there are
some ideas with b4 what is the concrete
approach and this is what Fabi is really
good at yeah what is the concrete
approach in this position that actually
puts Maxine's position in danger yeah
pressure arises him for for me it's
definitely the combination of those two
moves B 5 B 4 and Queen e5 as you
mentioned once he played the move Bishop
d6 playing for the dark squares well
having said a you should say B and I see
B for Queen e5 and Maurice what other
games have you got it because we've got
to move around there's a lot of games
going on sorry I'm looking at that game
there's something about this position
that concerns me because as you said
it's the timely issue when you a timing
issue when you have Knights against
bishops you normally you want your nice
to be doing something you you they you
don't want him to just look pretty yeah
looking pretty I mean unless you get
them killed unless they're anchored by a
pawn just sitting there looking pretty
you get chased around Knights neat sable
squares so I just want to make sure that
Knights have something to do while you
got your bishops who don't have to I
mean they look pretty means don't put
anything in my way and let me point
these got these bad boys at your head
and blow you up
so Maxime is looking for coordination at
all costs for I'll be looking for timing
I gotta get you now before you settle
down and go oh I just have two bishops
this is are gonna gonna restrict you
forever this King does feel the pressure
of this Bishop on a two so that's
interesting but the game that's really
fascinating and we haven't said a word
about this guy maybe we said two words
about him so far
digging the lore in which by the way
some of the betting odds are saying that
this is the guy they think is gonna win
the tournament we could put on our
attention in Fabiano but dig lorraine
has shown that he could absolutely win
this event no question about it means
he did qualify by coming in second
surprisingly so the world's Cup his
rating of 2805 says I'm one of only
three players in the world on the planet
who is over 2800 and he is the one who
has defeated Magnus Carlsen in a playoff
and he defeated Magnus a couple of times
in fact Magnus Carlsen going down after
dominating everyone else so we know and
a lot of people in the world are saying
that's the guy they want to see play
Magnus and we have to take a look at
that Chinese game but unfortunately race
there's a Russian guy that says nope
keep looking at my game because look at
necklace last move I didn't even think
that move was legal b5 played
encouraging you to take on d5 what is
going on in this position well I thought
the move Queen d3 was a great move
because it set up this wonderful
wonderful trap the move Queen d3 we were
talking about that pawn on c3 Queen d3
looks so logical let's eliminate that
pawn by the way please do take my pawn
on c4 Queen takes c4 d takes e4 black is
better but black suddenly faces this
move rook takes h7 threatening to take
on h8 with a check and suddenly oops and
there goes your queen why it's winning
so Queen d3 really gets a nice two
thumbs up and then suddenly comes to
this visual move b5 and it's like oh my
goodness what the heck has happened now
the problem is I see it is your king is
was always planning to go to g2 right so
taking on d5 with the Queen means that
well you're not gonna be playing King g2
anytime soon so that's the first thing
you've got there is this issue here with
this pawn coming marching down the board
already to c2 is like oh I'm sure when
he played Queen b3 b5 was not on his
radar that is to say onigiri is not
expecting that movement or Easons yeah
sorry-sorry leaves there are two big
reasons right because we talk about
drawback chess as a as an as a concept
when you make a move that looks good yes
it can look good but it always has a
drawback this always moves and there's
always a drawback to every single move
you play including bait by the way I
mean majors has such a lot of large plus
that does matter what the drawback was
but you always undefended square of some
kind when you make a move now Queen d3
the drawback to this move Queen d3 is it
no longer covers the b5 square knot
you're like that's not important is it
no way it turns out that it very much so
is important in this situation the other
thing about so that's one reason why you
might miss it the other reason is when a
partner is defending a square your brain
like may not even notice that it's the
square is protected even a strong
grandmaster in a league grandmaster like
giri this work is covered b5 is covered
when b5 happens you whoa it's weight
that's on the board it just suddenly
like like us like something just came
out of the dark and just showed up in
your face this move b5 yes the square is
actually the move is actually playable
it doesn't matter that you're covering
it with a pawn which normally would
prevent these kinds of moves so now you
see the C pawn is absolutely
rambunctious in his desire to run down
the board what a move by a nepo and man
Geary must just be shaking his head the
other thing is Gary was getting up from
the board walking around a lot during
the game because he was so prepared we
know Gary does that when he asked
reparation walking around usually he's
looking at other boards and not worried
about it because he's in his prep what
must he be feeling right now that his
prep is not helping him
well he's reeling backwards is what's
happening right now sorry a lot of
people look at gear and they say okay he
qualified by rating but he only
qualified by rating because the England
was second in the World Cup right
England had that rating spot guaranteed
for him even if he just lost every game
in 2019 Anish was his biggest
cheerleader he did in the grand prix yet
he got eliminated in the first round
every single time in the match played
and
match-play right he's been convincing
for a while I know that he's prepared so
strongly coming into this tournament he
went to Portugal for over a month with
the seconds he didn't say where the
location was but okay considering that
everything was in Portuguese Instagram
it wasn't hard to know he comes in
saying I need to prove something right
and he is not in the position he wants
to be in this first game he had a great
prep and it's not fully backfired
but it's backfiring this he's
uncomfortable you don't want to be
uncomfortable this is your prep this
isn't your white and your why this is
the game that you proposed right you
told Napa you're a gambler and I'm gonna
go to a shark position necklace like
bring it I'm gonna show you what it is
to gamble in chess I know how to handle
this position is better than you and
yeah fear is extremely strong but I
don't feel he is this type of player and
by the way we should point out if I'm
not mistaken please correct me if I am
didn't he this decline to play in one
tournament maybe was the last grand-prix
so that he didn't risk his rating
exactly he stepped out of an event
declined to play that's not a good sign
of somebody who's saying look I'm the
rightful challenger to that guy yeah
some people really I mean I'm not really
gonna fault him on that one I mean by
not playing he got a seat into this
candidate sternum I gotcha but you know
let's talk about
that Sinquefield Cup win Magnus Carlsen
was yeah he proposed the draw that would
have won Magnus a tournament the
position was still unclear right and
Magnus said now I want to play and he
literally could have lost that game and
end up tied with the other players
instead he declines it I saw Bobby do it
recently as well probably has the
tournament Clint I think he did it in
the candidates in here sure I get good a
draw
no no I don't think I'm gonna lose this
position let's play to me the sign of
the the gangsters the killers the Bobby
Fischer's of the world that Kasparov is
the Carlson's now Fabi showing himself
in that kind of group is they see a
situation inside a draw no it's back
back dooring into it
no I'm gonna show you how it's done and
so that but that may be a bigger saying
Giri we don't know if you have what it
takes he's gonna have a lot to prove by
the way he has played in a candidates
before he played a couple of Moscow
years ago in Moscow what are the most
famous results true every single game
but he could have won a game or two and
give it made himself a contender again
coulda woulda shoulda yeah this one
though we as we pointed out losing your
first game start the candidates we got
actually see this Chinese game and I was
about to say that going back in time
just up to this point after the move
Bishop g4 rook a three player okay three
but rookie 393 potentially preparing
Queen a 197 h3 Bishop h5 Queen b1 not
Queen a1 the Queen B 1 and here allowing
this night to come to c4 I don't know i
really be six yeah it's not about I
actually don't mind not giving up the
bishop you do not I like the idea that
when the knight on the end this night is
going to improve as I look at this
position a grandmaster looks at it what
am I what's my worst piece that I can
easily improve this night should be on
c4 exactly and I look at blacks position
I think this night is gonna give to c4
what can I do about it either I
eliminated immediately but I get the
pair of bishops I'm not really sure I
want to do that okay or I wait for it to
jump to c4 and I eliminate it with my
knight by putting the night on b6 okay
and that's why I hate them with b6 from
black because it solidifies a5 and c5
which are not a threatened at all I
don't write
I don't have to play this anytime soon
whites now we're gonna play b6 himself
so why not reserve the option of 96
maybe not today maybe not tomorrow but
at some point in the future exactly to
eliminate this an item that will
eventually land on c4 and that terrifies
me that I think that night on c4 it's
just a monster it's just a monster
exactly so b7 b6 something that moves
guys yes everything that was just said
like yes yes yes and the thing about
this position that concerned me in the
very start is actually when the most
seat forward sorry the movie for was
played as you can see I mean II for this
Botvinnik triangle for confirmation the
bishop on g2 you bury it right bury it
but you say I'm gonna command the light
squares I'm playing against that Bishop
sitting on c7 now that your bishop had
to hide you know scramble away from my
pieces I'm gonna dominate those light
squares and play is going to proceed
according to this very specific
structure that was set up so all right
you can play a5 that doesn't change
anything
you can play this move now I'm going
light squares again you can play this
one I'm gonna trade off and I'm gonna
solidify those light squares so now this
is the play except my bishop on g2 more
and more is looking like a bad piece
because of everything that happened but
my knight sees that c4 squared right the
light squares again but also let's make
no the d5 square it's all those light
squares that were just weakened so when
b6 happens you see more light squares
get weakened after these couple of moves
this move right here now it's like yeah
I've been thinking about lights moves
for a long time and you just kept
accelerating my desires so when you see
this next move happen which was Knight
f8 and you see Bishop f3 land on the
board because he's headed to d4 but
we're not worried about I wouldn't kill
that piece the moment it arrives so
Bishop f3 says now I finally get to
trade off this bad piece and after the
move Queen to g5 I believe was played h4
Queen back take Queen f3 and now we have
completed a plan begun with the move
on pawn to e4 we've got you are a
LightSquared domination and d5 looks so
rosy that are you guys see c4 I'm
looking at d5 as another square because
94 93 95 looks weight as a square so and
anytime you land on the weak d4 square
it's dying like that nice not gonna be
the equivalent and you're gonna be left
with that bad bishop on c7 and so that's
why all these books just seems have been
falling into wife's lap all this time I
think when you look at this position you
just see suffering this is a position
that with perfect play I have no doubts
black should hold but it's so difficult
to play with black right you don't have
a plan you're just kind of sitting back
yeah it feels like you're constantly
reacting to whatever white is doing and
you're just kind of playing a defensive
game not an easy game at all for Black
Knight
it goes with the flow of the light
squares
I guess I'm anti trading queen showing
my bias it also is a practical move you
are one power right now and you've been
offered a trade of Queens you know that
it's going to lessen the pressure but
now you move up
efore and then you imagine in your head
not only for f3
g4 rooks transferring to the oh yeah
yeah no that's pain and that's pain
that's nominate your Bishop on c7 again
it's a big it's a big it's crying it has
no future right exactly
let's just take a look at the lifetime
scores as you would expect England's
number one player should have an edge
over his Chinese college and this is the
public lifetime there are tournaments in
China that don't get reported to chess
games and things like that so yeah like
in the future it's not secret any junior
events and things they're very close in
age so the events inside China that are
not like the Chinese championship for
the Chinese League you know the big
events yes it's not a big big event you
might not have seen them it's like a lot
of opens in America
you might not the game might exist but
it's not been reported I got you
nonetheless a nice little edge and this
is a personal score and in the position
yes this is what we talked about
even if Geary gets this position it's
never associated you with wild
complicated positions it's actually gets
them once in a while like every super
grandmaster will but he really thrives
in those positional battles and those
snake-like I thought you didn't wrap
around your opponent yep um yeah she's
known for his craziness the England is
known for this
bow-bow construed and I was about to say
that ding Lorraine I mean come on guys I
mean 2019 was a breakout year for him it
was a fabulous performance and at the
Karen's Cup
here at the Cairns Cup the big
discussion and Gary Kasparov was on the
show for that discussion
I was asked of the eight players to ding
Lauren fabbi stood out as the clear
favorites and the other field you take
the field or would you take the two
players well
Gary Kasparov said I'm gonna take the
two players and giving on and then
suddenly the field change with mvl and
suddenly that scale kind of tipped a
little bit would you take the field or
would you take the two players actually
the Charis cup I did say that I was
gonna take the two players I was giving
even money before yes
but it is hard for me to really
understand the pros and cons as a
challenger because red job of he's kind
of a mystery figure in the chess world
it just doesn't play as much when you
think about active chess players at the
very top you kind of forget that our job
of stills around because he's so strong
he's so strong like particular seized
from his preparation is on point he
comes up with these great ideas
I think the entirety of some rosolie
maligns are alive because raja baath
came up with that he was a king's indian
expert like exactly like cairo really
understood the king seniya in the way
raja baath did exactly and the thing
it's just doesn't play so it's difficult
to assess is he really
that's strong is he really going to be
challenging the other players because he
doesn't play bike and so he doesn't play
the same field Cup he doesn't play the
grand chest or that as we saw in the
World Cup when he's on for meson he's
all for you take the field today right
now this tournament do you take the
field maurice or do you take the two
favourites
well there's a lot of data we could
throw a lot of data right but for
starters we've seen that the favorite
has not won the tournament since since
Magnus and he didn't even win it clear
he had to tie and win on tiebreaks not
only the favorite not win the number two
player didn't win either maybe you go
back the number the number two ranked
player didn't win the any of the last
three tournaments the number right so
we're going car we're talking about car
Bobby was number five in last advice
lady Berlin he was the number five
ranked player after disasters I can say
okay and he still won the tournament he
was number five rated player in the
world then we go back and we can talk
about car yeah Keon who is the number
seven ranked player in in the tournament
not in the world in a tournament
specific tournament we're talking about
he was the seventh ranked player in the
tournament and he won the tournament a
point clear we go back to on on who was
the number three ranked player in the
tournament if I'm not mistaken I'm sure
he wasn't one or two number one or two
I don't think so he had a really bad
year before that candidate so he might
have been but I know he wasn't one of
the top two exactly that means
numbers one and number two have not won
since we're going back to Magnus Carlsen
and even he has the clear runaway
favorite number two was like chronic
maybe at 28 10 maybe I maybe was our own
Ian but Magnus was 2872
he was the clear should have dominated
favorite right Oh Maurice the only time
we do have a phone call with us from
Egypt so we can tell us your name and
what is your question
hello I mean well first of all thank you
for making the commentary it's always
fun to follow the game with you guys
thank you
my question is if getting this I being a
wild card was abolished what other way
would you propose for employer to
qualify what would it be winning at a
certain tournament the breeding look
what would it be
that's a great question which was
abolished what wild card if the wild
card was abolished yes well there are a
lot of easy options right you can give
one more to the Grand Swiss you could
give another rating spot but what would
be a cool way to do it like a different
scenario jump right in I'm still
thinking it's a great question and I
think that's an important because there
have been so many discussions abolished
a wild card abolish a wild card what do
we replace it with because as I said
there's a lot of easy answers right
another rating guy or you know I you
know this might be controversial but a
fan-favorite a vote because somebody's
gonna rigged the voting system but if it
wasn't ripped that would be so cool like
I'm like yes I think if it wasn't rigged
I think by the way MBI would have been
the runaway favorite fan for you what is
the hardest by far tournament series in
the world right now oh that's easy
it's the grand chest or the grand
gesture you got to go through animals
yeah and I mean not animals you Vitry to
get any where is that and what about the
top qualifier from the grand chest or
right that whole series aligned up who
is not for example Magnus or isn't
qualified by other means if that had
been the case the qualifier this year
would have been one
mvl who lost in the finals to ding
Lauren in London right so and that I
mean and by the way we had Magnus in
that MBL defeated Magnus in order to get
to the finals and Magnus defeated Levon
Aronian
oh by the way our thoughts best wishes
are with LaVon and his wife Ariane
who wasn't a car accident but apparently
some broken bones but her life is out of
danger
so Iran's a sweet lady we wish you all
the best
absolutely well yeah sir let's take our
first break of the day we'll be right
back with absolutely more thrilling
chest
it's the 20/20 candidates guys thanks
for joining us we will be right back
with more action can you hear it it's
the sound of hope and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear really listen st. Louis University
celebrating its 200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of st. Louis Slough attracts
students and professors from around the
globe in 2015 Slough partner with the
same Lewis Chess Club to start a
top-tier collegiate chess team on the
very first year of the Peace inception
Slough obtained second best University
at the pan-american intercollegiate
chess championships higher purpose very
good st. Louis University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are back in round 1 of the 20/20
candidates what a show we have for you
guys this is do-or-die only one winner
out of this event and seven losers
there's no other way to look at this
tournament it's been the way
historically and we expect fighting
chance and we're getting it we are the
tournament so far the first round
preparation is dominating but is it
paying off let's take a look we had left
off in this craziness between onigiri
and Yanukovych in it for me actually
saying I don't care about your
preparation I love this kind of position
Sen let's see where the players have
landed well it was a smooth queen d3 and
suddenly this very visual move b7 b5
Anish was I think just rock backwards
after that move and he decided to try to
shut down the game by capturing on c3
and playing efore to break up this great
team of pawns that black has amassed in
the center on the inside certainly feels
with this move Queen c3 on e4 that
White's giving up ambition he's on he's
pulling the brakes exactly that's
exactly what he did he pulled the
parachute on let's just keep that yeah
apparently down upon so and after this
capture he's down to pawns but of course
he's getting one back pretty quickly
exactly he's wrecking that this pawn on
c4 he's gonna get captured but first he
was hoping that with this move rook h4
to be able to capture this and this
ambitious indeed Bishop e6 and well I
mean let's face it this preparation has
boomerang guys I mean Bishop c4 okay
looks like an amazing I mean castles is
so impressive because Bishop c4 looks
from afar like you're gonna be better
baby in this position after the trade of
the bishops because Bishop c4 I'm gonna
take on e6 with check how can there be
any kind of trickery I mean it's
incredible position he castles here like
hit the pawns hanging you're going to
lose it
he castles bishop
efore if I'm a niche looking from afar
this looks like I'm just stealing back
my palm with a better position except
there's a king move and in here gives
the the simple sidestep
I tried King h8 but King Jesus King g7
another semi remarkable move is you put
your king of h8 seems like the more
natural thing to do but now the
statement is by black what do you do
about this weird pin I got I got a rook
c8 coming I mean this is deep right you
castle so that you can play King g7 so
that you can then ask the guy what he's
gonna do about the situation and it
looks like he should have some kind of
way to deal with it and yet every move
walks into something else I'm worried I
gotta ask you are hopefully you can ask
the engine yg7 and not h8 yeah because
AJ was my first choice as well what is
the main line after a trade them it
makes that difference right why would
you want the King a little bit more
exposed
yeah the King on g7 okay I will take a
look at the board yes exactly so in this
position I would just love to play the
move Bishop d5 except Bishop takes d5 is
with a check also rook ca I'd love to
play rook c8 but a decision take C 6 is
check so we're gonna move our King now
the choice is h8 or g7 and Maurice is
going to answer that question for I'll
give you a hint drawback chess okay
let's get to drawback just what's the
drawback to King h8 it's not on g7 what
was it doing what was it doing on g8
that is no longer doing and that it
would be doing on g7 g7 protects f6 bow
what else is more important h7 but it
also defense a chest on h8 so it's doing
what else is it the other rook
the Queen and it's hitting not not 83
because it's check on c4 right you can't
right now but soon sooner and he did
take on c4 well sooner or later that
rook on on FA F fakes gonna hang
undefended purity sunshine and that's
the reason got shot there so you gotta
look at the g7 keeps the connection to
that rook okay and now I need did take
so here we go will he find the connected
rule h8 is of course a safer feeling
move but your rook on f8 would hang in
that line and allow the Queen to escape
so now it's all about keeping this rook
under attack oh I'm at the defense
beautiful move I mean castles just going
into the line it seemed strange and then
you Castle and then you come up with
this waiting move and say you cannot fix
it the problem is you play a move like
this one by the way we could have gone
here let's say you play King any chain
Queen d3 unpinned completely you're
ready to move your except you allow
another move Bishop to f5 hey your rook
spend but now I can play Queen a3 hello
your rook is hanging in this line and it
doesn't matter so again that's why you
want your King on g7 with this now you
cannot play this much Bishop f5 you got
zero zilch
you just lose hand over the exchange
right so that's the point
and so here Bishop takes c4 if he finds
King g7 which no reason why he shouldn't
if and especially if he's pausing right
now a nice giri is gonna have a lot of
work ahead so what's the line after King
G some no there are there is some work
here to consider the move the Queen can
move like let's say here for example the
routes going to attack it and question
this connection where's the Queen gonna
go it everywhere it goes it's walking in
to pin C 2 C 3 D 3 anything that guards
this Bishop will walk into a pin the
line I'm intrigued by is this one what
if I take that's probably a draw but
you're gonna suffer this one yes will
you want to go into this line after
capturing you have bishop and rook
Bishop and rook and pawn
not even a pawn you actually only even
in pawn so this line after rook takes b3
you can also just capture I think it's
not gonna it's not a matter in the long
because you have to defend this pawn as
well the queen is gonna torture you and
the main difference is this part
formation these pawns can motion down
the board and create some kind of
difficulty so this would be a lot of
suffering for Giri in this game well if
he finds some of King g7 yesterday take
us to the Russian matchup we haven't
really good find King g7 okay because
yes we have actually there's a kind of
funny thing we were on a break and we
had just seen this position that we need
we were anticipating d4 Knight h4 kind
of ideas well II to e4 kind of an echo
move of the a Chinese game between ding
Lauren and went wow e to e for blocks
the bishop on g2 but has a very specific
strategic aim as we're about to find out
Bishop d6 high-stepping potential for d4
Knight 84 and this is sasha is looking
at is a parking a knight on f5 and
perhaps using his F pawn as a battering
ram f2 F for we were we were kind of
focused on d4 there for a while but
maybe f4 first and knock out the e5 pawn
for the f2 pond and then play d4 and it
was funny right about here I was
recalling a game from the romantic
school of chess where there was an f4
takes d4 two eggs e5 takes and somebody
just crushed black and I can't remember
who the players were but he just gave up
all of his pawns so he could get this
battering ram in the center with t4 and
e5 well certainly but you can also just
take on that for of course of course I
mean and let's see what has happened
actually so f4 was played no yes yes or
was played okay and they took on f4 and
Richard took back on f4 with the Jeep on
which also prefers the movie 5 is that
command I see your bar from afar it
gives white a little bit of an edge our
chess Amador
blacks position leave it I think it's
just trash
write me five d4 d5 I wouldn't I don't
understand what is blacks planning here
he I'm throwing backwards to because I'm
a I light be central pawns I like this
Bishop on g2 Alexander Grichuk is a
natural-born Kings Indian defense player
he loves the Kings Indian defense from
both the white and black side and this
is a game that's right up his alley
is is it that the knight on h4 is badly
placed it seems the thing blacks okay
shaken before it's playing f6 just
holding back wide spawns but it's
difficult to believe him perhaps this is
the modern chess new players with new
understanding like Kirilenko saying look
out a hundred-year-old this is the way
we play chess nowadays it's okay for
black don't you worry I got this under
control and Grizz shook 1-0 against I
like Sanka with one draw like Cinco
actually very interesting has to not
played against many of these players
think this is the first time actually
this might be the first time in
candidates that of two players haven't
faced each other I can't imagine that
being a scenario before and I just about
to say I mean how much experience does
he have against all of the other players
in the field maybe that what we just saw
is kind of typical of his it's very
typical he asked not played I think
against Bobby maybe wearing how to he
hasn't played against the Chinese
players yeah just in experience
completely right so he needs to bring
his game say I got new things I got this
new energy in chess
he's being coached by Peter Svidler so
he definitely has not that's the voice
that's pretty bitter in there Maurice
what do you got for us now I didn't know
about this business about the coaching
but Peters feel oh that I didn't know
that about that new to me right and I'm
wondering if you're Peter Spindler yeah
you've played in candidates before I
live won a Russian championship eight
times you played these guys you know
their ins and outs and weaknesses and
all that you're giving your young charge
all this but can you imagine Peter
sitting there things I mean it's be hard
not to I know Peter such a nice guy
that that you know he may not have these
kind of thoughts at least too often but
every once in a while he might be
thinking why you about it but okay Peter
you know he joins us often a very dear
friend and colleague but yeah
certainly I think maybe many would say
he's stronger than his charge at the
moment but nevertheless it's the future
of Russian chess we're talking about
guys can we look at this position we
really like black here white a white
sorry we really like right here I like
to plan a bringing a king over guarding
this pawn playing on the light squares
preparing everything before you finally
hit him in the head with f4 maybe
getting the Knight to f5 or d5 carding
those kind of threats make his knight
back up and then eventually you get the
palm Bray that you need to play but the
immediate f4 lands on the board with no
attending preparation right none as we
just played and the thing about this
move is it allows to capture here when
you must you cannot capture back I mean
I can't conceive of you capturing back
here and allowing this pawn to just
drops of the knight can go back on the
next move that looks wrong yeah so that
means you have to take to the bishop
okay in this position okay and now okay
you're still on this guy but Knight
takes so Bishop takes doesn't really
help because I will hang Knight takes
pawn takes and now this position is that
is this position great for white because
of this knight dominating this bishop
well now this bishop does have strengths
here now you may say what the bishop is
bad the engine comes up with this very
dynamic shot f5 right away wrecking
White's pawn structure looking to get
the rook into the game room other
weakness on this square and now if you
play e5 suddenly h4 starts to be a
possibility later you could double a law
on this line so the King can't just
leave it's not as easy this position
it's suddenly much much sharper a king
might just park itself on the e6 square
this one is super interesting now when
before it look like you're just gonna
get
your face stepped on I like literally
now this one I don't know
and for impatient maybe impatient but
you know yeah sorry look at this
position maurice asus is this that's
good for white visually i would say yes
yeah yeah when i look at it i have the
open g file your pressure on d3 is
completely irrelevant because i will at
some point defender with the rook on g3
right so what do i care my king is gonna
go to e2 i understand the engine now
understands chess so well you know the
new stock fish and you Leela they do
such a wonderful job at understanding
weaknesses on long term plans right and
they've changed dramatically the way we
see a lot of positions because when I
see this position I think it's just a
matter of time before I find a
breakthrough but nowadays the
interesting blacks better yeah but look
F what is that but no problem the
problem is timing Alejandra if I had a
king maybe on III already if maybe if I
could play the move f5 myself already
like put upon and at 5 I don't care
about your dark squares because now my
your gg line is a huge problem for ever
my king is guarding the one weakness
I'll put a rock on f3 I'll double on the
g5 I'll tie you down I'll bring my
knight back to e3 to d5 I mean who the
problem is concretely after f5 e 5 which
f5 has been played if I was playing
actually I put a Rakhi on e6 but wang
hao just dropped a rook on e6 and so
much for the g file as a rook is gonna
go to g4 and whose weaknesses are what
whoa suddenly you're defending multiple
weaknesses the deep on the two the f1
and the H pawn and that Bishop will be
able to get back to d8 I mean this one I
know going to d4 sorry that is an arrow
on
[Laughter]
a little bit of a wake up there and five
all the board we don't have the movie
five just yet but it does seem like the
character the position has changed from
something that dinkler was controlling
we're talking about the boy constrictor
radical position that he likes certainly
looks different
Oh without question did he yeah know
that impatient move promise this just
drops a pawn right exactly it can rip t4
that's the exactly and I don't get the
nice chance what Maurice was talking
about to bring my knight to the d5
square violence poor information as well
favors the bishop the fact that his
bishop came alive with this move f5 he
did not see this pawn break he reminds
me of the beef I break in the game with
neppo against Geary Wow your brain just
doesn't notice it somehow because the
square is protected by a pawn right it's
one of those moves that GM's miss I did
a video on that by the way and we're
gonna check it out in chess base I
didn't get paid to plug that by the way
players will miss we talked about this
before what's up my moves retreating
moves are Mose you'll miss suddenly why
are you going all the way back to switch
sighs OH
where did that come from absolutely
discovered attacks discovered checks
allowing discovered checks or moves
people will miss when Geary saw Bishop
takes c4 in this game if I go back a
move here he thought I got this thing on
your queen alicent wait a minute you can
make a way to move like this one a king
boosts knight retreats King moves
unusual King moves
these are moves that top players when
they're going straight into your line
gear half sacrifice this Queen would
deed Queen b3 recreated on boards east
education board always saying I'm gonna
suffer but this was the best guy he's
got it's gonna try to make a draw and
survive so there's certain most strong
players will miss and one of them
absolutely is moves where a pawn is
protecting a square you're trained from
birth almost at least the birth of your
chest career have a pause guard to the
square nothing can go there you just
don't think about it so your brain gets
trained over the years
decades that these are the kind of moves
you'll see strong Clara's miss and we've
seen it happen maybe twice in this event
so far f5 you think if he had seen the
movie f5 ding Loren would've played at
four I mean here and notice that firemen
said whoa no no no you're getting too
much play dude you're getting a lot he
missed this move and is to deal with the
sudden shift in energy where he was
suppressing everything his opponent had
and suddenly black has tremendous play
Thank You Maurice Andrew well we have a
little bit of a special feature dropping
some chess knowledge for you I know a
lot of fast one to know not only about
the ACE but I have to play for
professionals so let's go with our Chess
Club staff to see what they have in
store for us
tricky traps all right thank you guys
I'm Jonathan France and I'm very happy
to be here I'm very excited to be on the
show thank you for allowing me this
wonderful opportunity I did want to take
a very small break from the incredibly
professional chess to mentioned some of
the stuff that happens at the real level
the club level and today I did want to
share with you the Siberian trap I had a
work colleague asked me just yesterday
he said I keep playing they play e4 I'm
a big Sicilian player but all the time
I'm running into this move d4 the Smith
Morra gambit and I need a recipe I only
have five minutes tell me what I should
do so if you're in the same boat and you
have problems with the Mora here is what
I recommend at this point you should
accept the gambit when you play d4 their
idea is to place c3 and when you take
they're going to try to develop their
pieces as fast as possible now the mind
of an average Mora player thinks of only
one thing they want to play Knight to f3
Bishop to c4 Castle Queenie to follow
this basic blueprint of bringing the
bishop out start putting the rooks in
the middle look around for sacrifices
and checkmate the player with black but
I do have a little way of playing that
can get you out of all of this trouble
and set a little trap for white so white
could be in trouble after you play
Knight to c6 the main move Knight f3
and now the move a six among others this
is one of the great moves to play you
also won't run into any move order
tricks if you are a time on/off
con player so this is particularly
well-suited if you were gonna play six
on move to against most Sicilians now
they will continue with what they
normally do Bishop to c4 and instead of
the move a six we can start to set a
little trap with this move Queen to c7
this is taking control over the e5
square so now we're ready to play Knight
f6 next without getting harassed white
players will tend to Castle now and you
can play the move Knight to f6 the trap
is now nearly set and if they follow the
regular script that anymore a player has
been taught they play Queen e2 now is
the time to set an excellent little trap
the move Knight to g4 actually is
setting something up very devious and
threatening to win the game on the spot
and at first it may look like just a
total pasture move you've moved the
knight again for a second time look at
white White's already Castle have got a
whole bunch of pieces out this must be
silly nonsense but you'd be surprised
even in the chest base database over 50
people have played this move h3
including a 2600 rated player
Grandmaster has fallen for this trap it
happens all the time especially if
you're a blitz player you're gonna get
this non-stop if you do play this way so
after h3 hopefully you guys can see the
trap I will give you a moment to think
it out what the big hint here is Black
is looking at this h2 square if it
weren't for this knight on f3 we would
already have a checkmate so the way to
try to remove that knight is with the
brilliant move Knight to d4 attacking
the knight and the queen so white is
best advised here just to give up the
Queen not such an easy task but
obviously if you do take this Knight you
are gonna run in to a checkmate happens
all the time with that being said there
are alternatives if you do move your
queen and if you know I didn't wanna
lose my queen well it's still checkmate
Knight to f3 and however they take back
the same checkmate so this happens all
the time
now you may be wondering well okay I
play some pretty good people I'm not
gonna fall for it the people I play they
don't run into this they're gonna see
this trap
to play h3 and fall for it what will
they normally do another big mistake you
see all the time in this position is
rook to d1 even some pretty decent
players have done it the idea of
controlling the d4 square is very
obvious so why not do it with a rook
keep developing pieces that rook usually
goes there anyway and now though black
plays Bishop to c5 just putting pressure
on the f2 pawn and yeah why it's already
in very bad shape if you have to play
the move Bishop to e3 you simply take
with the knight white is still upon down
and his position is horrible here so
this is another way that happens all the
time a more successful white player here
instead of falling for all of this might
play the move Knight to b5 this is the
appropriate way of defending against the
threat the night not only attacks the
Queen but also defends the d4 square and
after they go back there is the option
of now playing h3 notice how 94 no
longer works because it's covered by the
knight on d5 so black has two options
here I argue they're both very good for
black one is to set another trap this is
now the fishing-pole trap so if the
first one doesn't work and you feel like
risking it up playing another one feel
free to go for this one
the point is now if you take the knight
you are absolutely lost again as white
you take back and you're gonna win this
tonight because if the knight does move
say it just goes somewhere it's the same
sort of checkmate on the h-file
so I do hope that that does help you
guys and we will stay around with us
please we're gonna continue our coverage
here in just a moment it's a very
classical trap what are the things I
like about it is that it's completely
sound there's 94 it doesn't have a
reputation it's actually just good for
black right why it's supposed to not
castle and that position is supposed to
make any any other move but I like traps
that are also sound they make me feel
really nice that I'm not just
sacrificing my position hoping my
opponent doesn't know it while Jonathan
was giving that nice little tricks and
traps we were just we thought that
kirakira was playing abominably he yeah
he played Knight a5 and he was like he's
just setting traps on the board
okay Bishop a4 I hope he doesn't see it
because I can win an exchange and
shockingly he saw it he saw it need to
eat sidestep Queen d8 that I hope he
doesn't see it I'll take the knight he
saw that one how about this one Knight
c4 it's a cooler version a very nice
version you take the knight oops there's
a trap he saw that one too I mean the
guy hasn't missed a trick suddenly he
essentially black forced white to
basically dominate the center and he put
his knight on those c4 square and black
really hasn't made progress is it
because black is just fishing for an
idea Maurice I mean it just like he just
didn't come up with a plan and all he
could come up with was maybe a bad plan
and he's played at the Move f7 f5 I
think I'm up to date with the players
but we're up to date
also notice the time 3 minutes and 45
seconds for gristick 5 minutes and 45
seconds we were definitely going to be a
factor we know that you should be
possible but Maurice what what what is
going on Ken black somehow hold on for
this position again my understanding
blacks busted yeah it's just terrible we
all hate it the injured hates it enough
said
cool we're just gonna see what happens
in that game in the meantime this has
happened in this game rook GC we saw the
rookie 6 rook g6 maneuver by Wang Hao
against his countryman one of the
favorites in this event
ding Lauren who has also played in only
one candidates prior to this one the
last one that Fabi won in Berlin there
was a quietly strong performance by ding
Lorraine going +1 winning one game and
drawing the rest of his games so he made
his presence known but not so much as to
compete with the top players or the
entire title itself so he's hoping for
much more here but not off to an
auspicious start as he's allowed this f5
break on the different circumstances a
route going to g4 I wrote going to d4
this pawn to h4 will hang Bishop
dropping back to d8 the king will sit on
e6 and that's all that in that square
now what's odd about this is the engines
think whites okay with a move like 93
but but I I wouldn't care about anything
the engine has to stay in a position
like this one unless you can completely
shut down blacks initiative because
black now sees swings and punches and
possibilities where before he just saw
dire suffering right now Dean Loren has
to be super careful another player who
is going to have to be careful
he's a nice Giri because he has decided
to go for this position his pardon
Bishop as harmonious as they can be so
no problem there it is true that if only
he had he could pick this part off the
board and make it a white pawn on e3 for
example then he would be thinking is
there is there some kind of possible
fortress I could set up right it's very
close to a fortress if this were a white
pawn on e3 now he's thinking I got a
bishop in a pond maybe I can maybe
that's enough to give me counter play so
I can create maybe some kind of fortress
in compensation
unfortunately this pawn can be a
battering ram and these pawns will go
down the board as well a potential
creation of a passed pawn the key in
this kind of position is going to be
what can the Queen attack for starters
not so easy to do and if not that then
where are the past pawns
if a passed pawn shows up on the board
there's big trouble
now white does have one here but it
looks like you can't move it looks like
blacks gonna be the one who's gonna slow
this guy down and that part is also
going to be near the king as well so
that's what black is gonna look for
something with the pawns coming down now
this rook wishes it we're back home I
can tell you that it was going to d1
hanging out with the rest of the crowd
it will look to try to get back into the
game as well the game is not easy to win
for black for sure but pure suffering
blacks no longer thinking he's gonna
lose his game he's thinking I should
score the point nice Thank You Maurice
for that dear with only two minutes left
but remember that he's very very close
to move 40 and once he reaches move 40
he will have an extra 50 minutes so he's
in control he's not really in any danger
timewise the move rook g8 it was really
a shock move for me I was thinking real
cage
was automatic guys I gotta tell you for
the first round game I even though MBL
may not be the highest ranked player in
the group this game for me is such a key
game between fabbi and MVL if a bee who
stands much better in my opinion much
much better much better
I really like the opposite color bishop
middle games it's all about King
position who's King is safer and with
the pawn on h3 the dark squares for
white are compromised and the other
thing that stands out is this pawn on a5
of course if White's bishop gets to b7
then you can say this is weak but right
now the FI pawn is a weakness there's
some darks whereas issues you how always
have to be careful that black is gonna
set up a battery and something goes
really v and Queen d5 have been played
Queenie five on the board Queen d5 yes
and I cannot take on b2 because I asked
you might get made it I don't actually
get made it on their fate but I think
it's just a draw right if I go Queen
takes e5 Queen takes a two row cafe
check I take on that fade you take on
their fade Queen g8 and I think just a
move Queen b6 I'm a pawn grubber the
family over here guys I'm a pawn up I'm
not saying this is win no no no no but
I'm saying I mean well yeah exactly it's
a two result game and for fabbi you'll
be happy to get here so he does have
this possibility that he can grab the
pond or get your side stuff oh you okay
well you guys are talking about the
mission name right yes the middle game
with the opposite color brushes can i
play like Queen e3 I think something
like this okay say I'm gonna keep up the
pressure I don't know what my threat is
but I'm keeping up the pressure exactly
it's not like you're meeting on g1
you're just having two white what what
are you gonna do I'm thinking there's
Bishop for whatever reason should really
be on the Kings side so let me just i
plonk it here got ideas maybe if a pet
and I'm a musician I think here we
emphasize the
difference of the bishops right and here
black plays Jesus
it kills the bishop on v1 true and my
king on the dark squares should always
be safe yes it exposes the diagonal but
the diagonal will be controlled by a
dark squared bishop at some point I'll
put the bishop on d4 something along
this lines right and this one also feels
like it's suffering for life no question
about it I like blacks position
I like grabbing the pawn as well I don't
see the real drawback to to grabbing the
pawn queen takes b2 if you don't go into
this Queen ending no you have to why did
you play Queen d5 yes and I wondered the
same as you made such a compelling
argument so I started making moves here
okay it turns out we can get to an
interesting position how do you play
Queen takes Queen takes in Queen c6 and
the a pawn look at you in the pawn back
immediately Queen e2 stops all that
nonsense before basics can't be touched
because they work on f1 and now the move
rook to c1 and these are real specific
hard moves to find defensively Queen c6
may not be so hard but rook c1 the thing
about rook c1 is the move b4 is not
playable
hey now offended that's defended your
rook is not contributing to attacking
anything right at the moment so are you
saying well what are you doing you just
dropped your pawn but now look at this
nice move Queen to b7 no keeping an eye
on this pawn attacking this one's and
we're going straight through and don't
leave with your queen so easily because
this Queen also has its own ideas a
queen e7 sighting could come depending
on where your Queen goes so this one is
not that easy to defend everything
remember b1 could also happen at any
moment you cannot leave the back rank
with your rook so this pawn maybe has
gone too far
down the board so the engine looking way
ahead and found a way to defend in this
position if you take on b2 if you just
continue this line I know it's deep deep
deep deep but Queen d2 it does defend
the pawn on b4 it does attack the room
sets up maybe for rook e1 check on a
good day no no rookie one check for you
rip to c8 hitting the back rang now that
your
you'll get a check but where you want to
go here if you a surprise see the bar
but it's just like not keeping see from
white side I think that Queen b7 mu star
move absolutely difficult to see about
Maxine was the kind of player he was
very specifically tries to solve
problems with that takes two great
calculators in the world but at these
two you wouldn't sit here and be stunned
by this by the way I didn't answer a
question from a long time ago you know I
hate when I watched shows watching a
show
you're leaving us hanging and and and
and the questioner I've seen this so far
with this virus issue quite a bit and it
really gets under my my skin when a when
a reporter says oh we have a question
for you this is the question and the
person says interesting question and
they never answer the question and start
talking about something else
wait a minute what about that really
good question why didn't you answer the
question it's maddening you had a
question for me earlier about what I
take the field yes the top two and you
guys actually took the question from me
because you have to go to a caller so I
wasn't able to get there so now I want
to make sure I don't you know that I
don't like damn right so so getting back
would I take the field all the data says
I should take the field despite the fact
that fabi's clearly the number one
player in this tournament
he's far ahead of anyone else except
maybe ding Lorraine might argue I'm
right there you know I'm super powerful
absolutely but you've got mvl who showed
up and that really changed things quite
a bit
you've got nepo and the way neppo played
so far and then live number five player
in the world but the way he's played so
far shows you why he's one of the top
players in the world you've got a Gris
Chuck who could get things done Anish I
would give away lesser weight to the
other three players so not by much
but I'm and history has said that's so
easy for the
favorites but not by much I might take
the field I would take the field but
that said if you if you said to me but
who will you pick but just straight up
hey baby it's probably all day it's
probably all day no question about it
we'll jump right back in there we guy
Christmas game who's starting to play on
the increment do you know how much he
loves doing that he's got 48 seconds
left to make about 12 moose of chess and
he gets thirty seconds for each
completed move is completed Moser he's
not in danger of actually flagging so
let's take a look at the position right
now well he's got this huge pawn Center
and when we left it we just left it it
after the move of f5 he did come
eventually decide to play e5 creating
these passed pawns now don't don't for a
moment think you can capture this pawn
he grandmasters don't usually blunder
pawns Queen c4 check captures the knight
so Knight xe3 would have been a terrible
decision for black after 92 the Knights
were traded and white is ready to rumble
d5 d6 you have to play Bishop e6 and now
you guys go for a blockade and if you if
black can get and moves like b5 and
maybe Bishop d5 yeah we've got some
chances but no no it just feels like
White has made too much progress I don't
know there's something wrong with c4 I
was about to say it was there something
wrong with d5 I yes
c6 is okay 6d sex looks terrible and
yeah this just looks terrible wait a
minute and your structure collapses
that's a big problem
that was the Queen moves exactly exactly
I was that I was putting a lot of oomph
behind this pawn on d5 which explains
just nicely explains why he played the
move Bishop e3 okay
gotcha because there yes pretty quickly
see sex was played to now did your plan
B 5 and Bishop t5 blockading the light
squares v6 played a four well stop and
we stopped B 5 in getting sense I think
I see the move 86 yep why is this pawn
not hanging Maurice girl have an engine
[Laughter]
he could give a good play and give up
the b-pawn but it looks like he's
looking for some tricks Queen takes I
don't see them the mover v8 doesn't work
here and the thing about you because you
can't Bluff him because with no time on
the clock he took on a sex Wow Wow
he said I also don't get it though but
the problem for black is the desirable
he's trying to get a blockade it's
trying to play for b6 b5 but he doesn't
want to give white one of the Ponce's
going through but white saying look I'm
ready to play C for D 5 and it's just
lights out
so a6 was allowing Queen b6 now that's
nearly hanging and if that see pollen
drops man knows you but you're gonna be
begging to no choice I mean you may not
like being pawns down who does but at
least in this case you you do have ideas
of maybe trying to ensnare the Queen and
again if you can get to play rook takes
a 4 and only be one pond down maybe some
chances but it sure looks like Russia's
in controller in the game sure looks
like griffix and controller so nine
moves away from time control so still
quite a bit away from it 44 seconds for
Gris Chuck though in County he's
counting and but he's about yeah at the
moment at the moment he will loose a
four I don't see your way through the
family for remember the rook FB 8 is
currently quite a threat right in this
position I would probably start with
rook e1 myself and ready to give up my
queen for the two
and maybe please give up your moon for
the tour it's all kind of you okay so
queen bee rupee one with the idea maybe
queen b7 so rook a4 we have quick moves
and we have a queen bee to was played on
the board on the board and quickly Alex
& Co makes a for absolutely he still
feels like he's just down upon okay so
what Roque one play okay which
apparently the engine doesn't like
although I don't know why that's a very
human moon maybe just right made and
you're starting to get some kind of the
good thing about his position he got his
blockade yeah you're down upon but now
see force not coming d5 is not coming
that's right
the bishop on III is bad so
strategically his position has improved
a lot for one pawn for one point you
know it was a good game yeah in some
ways yeah the reefs over to you quick
action there no question about it
just quickly jumping over to this game
straight it looks like a queen trade did
occur far be trading Queens this one now
I think will disagree should be drawn in
doesn't look like you can win this pawn
without dropping as a pawn so just
breaking news it looks like this one
should be a draw
well that's Queen trade I'm not pleased
with that back to Grisham for just a
second so the engine did my croquet Juan
did it have an alternative what was the
alternative that was I mean I'm looking
at rook a to that was why I played rook
a one kind of like my hand right just to
stop her okay - I'm not really sure okay
he did play rook anyone and do we have a
move yes Rick FA a plate okay make sense
we have to defend the rook and you want
to play rotate to still exactly it's
becoming sharp because I'm trying to
figure out how to defend against well if
I trade all the rooks off the board how
do you think that that is giving black
too many drawings that if I take and I
take and it
money three is not its greatest piece
the world ladies in the bike square
blockade hard to break not only that the
King on g1 or g2 is going to be very
vulnerable Queen d5 Jacqueline Queenie
for gonna come into the position it
doesn't feel right
yeah great conversation for the pawn yes
sorry he started around Wow well you
know when you have to play quickly
well Richard didn't have to do you don't
find the most accurate moves necessarily
to was maybe just not some point
something went wrong but Maurice yes yes
wow that's well that's going is still
gonna be a lot moves there
this one has made time control the one
between an fo and Geary and this one
rook hae for rook - h8 and rooted sorry
e root 2 da would check King dropping
back and now the move Bishop to d1 he's
trying against o is Geary to make sure
the move III doesn't flap his position
open exactly this one will just so wreck
everything so you have to play Bishop to
d1 so it's a visual move because you got
the rook hanging and the bishop now
attacking the Queen the Queen has
options are where to go it looks like f5
is the best square I think it would love
to stay on this third rank so you can
still get this move III and I'm curious
as to why and they've they've made the
40th and this is the 41st move this move
looks like it makes a lot of sense
apparently rook to d4 hits this pawn and
now you can't play you three because of
the four just Queen c3 very similar it's
what I keep Queen e1 and maybe also e3
oh and stop the rook d4 that's a good
looking moving the engines approve as a
matter of fact Queen c3
very strong looking move to keep a lot
of control over the game you do leave
this pawn on h5 but III is gonna be such
an explosive move with the Queen e1
threat that looks tough well I would bet
Geary is gonna lose this game because
it's so hard to hold it up against all
these threats and a perfectly animated
Queen that just looks like it's not just
animated but dynamic going to cause some
huge explosions in White's position the
Christian game is going exactly as we
thought all the roofs have been created
and Bishop takes g2 on top so we were
talking
about that weakness of the King giving I
like Cinco great chances to hold but we
do have a phone call from Omaha let's
see we can get connected hello
tell us your name and your question this
is Carlos from Omaha first of all I got
a I got an interesting comments for you
guys you are are by far the best team
that I've seen come any lunch s and that
you guys had like three different
playing styles so basically over one
game we get three different perspectives
over it and nobody there so like ego
that you know y'all step on each other
so y'all kind of hit everyone in that
you know everybody can see their flames
out but my question is regarding a
affair like MDL and then let's take a
hobby or a Jeffers are you know Bobby
and Jeffrey song will play just about
any and everything on any given day and
play it like really good and then you
have or mvo say hey I'm a certain target
come getting this is mines in my
backyard what you got for them and I'm
curious for you guys can a two-part
question the pros and cons of both hyper
players you know and then secondly in
your heyday when you was playing which
type of player would you like to play
against and why and now take my answer
off here yesterday I'm the great comment
I think we should put at least one of
the games up on the board while we're
doing this analysis I think this one is
kind of dead let's just go right any
other
many of them and I'll take the first
crack because I'm Carl azuz question is
just great I recently read this book
about Vichy anons life that's a chess
player okay and he actually mentioned
that there were two types of players so
once it go very narrow and super deep
and the ones that go super wide but the
depth there's just not enough I'd be
shallow right right and what he said
it's also stylistically they're both
difficult it just depends who you are
who you match better against right that
you have to have a little bit of both at
the very top
now of course Maxime is the greatest
exception to this because he is
incredibly narrow right now personally I
like the wider players because I feel I
have understanding of a lot of positions
right but my death isn't quite there
when I meet somebody that's very
entrenched in their repertoire I have a
lot of problems breaking it right
whereas when I get interesting positions
against people with a wide variety of
styles and repertoire I think I can find
better but it really does come down to
personal style who do you match better
against some players do better against
them we all some players do worse yeah
yourself how would you describe yourself
I'd deep and narrow or wide and maybe a
little challenge definitely on the wide
side I have done deep reparations in my
past when I was a more active player but
always liked to experiment I was always
getting bored with just playing one
opening which means I never really
understood any of them right because you
play a lot you don't get this
familiarity so you're like a big mix a
myself Maurice wild and shallow baby was
more narrow now for me today right now I
look at Magnus Carlsen and I just go wow
nothing there guys plays everything yep
and it ain't shallow it's amazing that
was a big leap when he became number one
in the world
he was already he was still known as
somebody that didn't have that exquisite
opening preparation right he was known
as somebody that played everything and
then he added that element he added that
deep preparation for a lot of these
things coming up with novel
tee's I remember that game in one of the
grand Chester she played against Dingley
around with the black pieces in a
catalan just uncorking this excellent
novelty and just blowing nothing around
off the board he how did that element
and he just became unstoppable for a
while and that is the kind of
transitions that's difficult for players
to make but Magnus has been able to do
it and that's one of the reasons he
because you need to change you don't get
to the top and do whatever you've been
doing and keep at the top you need to
change me to evolve you need to keep
putting new ideas on the chess board and
that's what he's done right well for me
Gary Kasparov was an in remarkably hard
worker I mean he kept coming up with
opening novelties his number one in the
world for 20 years I mean come on
and like you say I mean he kept mostly
for but boy those matches with Karpov he
could add d4 and he widened the net over
to you Maurice and the match up with
well well we have some breaking news
this game as we suspected did and in a
draw game has concluded MVL and Fabiana
Caruana so mvl has shown yes indeed I
can play the favorites in the event I
may get into a little bit of trouble but
you got to beat me and he we know he's a
hard man to be you try to put your hand
on him Magnus Carlsen saw that a few
times in London that just happened the
finals of the grand chest tour and nvl I
mean slippery as an eel is this van very
difficult to beat will he get the wins
that he needs right now he doesn't care
it's a fourteen round event and usually
the score that wins this event the
normal score to win yeah plus three plus
three we're talking fourteen games plus
three is what normally wins this event
probably did go plus four when he won
but plus three is all you need normally
to take first and in a couple of cases
took clear first let's remember that
when Fabi wanted with plus four plus
three was also good enough he played to
that so
so these players know it's a long haul
there in the long haul plus three is all
they need so a draw is not a bad
starting result but the game
to watch is this one and it's nothing by
the way I want to just go back just a
moment we talked about pragmatism in
this moment here the move Bishop h4
guess what the engine was screaming for
this move Bishop takes h4 right now you
can play it but he played rook d4 it was
move 37 this is the most important point
I should make he put and rook these he
played rookie 492 he played rook d5
Knight e3 and any plate is wrote back to
d7 move 39 he couldn't get all the way
to where he wanted to now the engines
have a very sharp booth here d4 which
apparently liquidates the game and puts
right back in business to get a draw we
can get into that but instead move 40
had been a quiet move he said rook be -
I don't want to do anything dramatic and
suddenly Bishop h4 lands on the board
now his initial point no doubt was this
move rook to h2 that he had a rook h1
sighting before now this will rookie 3
check can happen and after like where do
you put your king it looks like King e 2
is the most logical move but to move g5
appears out of nowhere and whoops this
one is all black dangler ranan might
bills down in trouble right now imagine
the one of the favourites to win and by
the bookies I can tell you I looked at
it before I came here
right the bookies were saying Dingling
run by a little bit all those
calculations they learned by a little
bit does hey what about Fabi no Dengler
ran by a little bit all their
calculations their simulations well
don't lose the first runner you gonna
have to pull off at all because nobody
has lost the first round in the
candidates in this format and come back
and won the tournament and your
countrymen being so rude
thank you seriously like seriously we're
homeboys right I mean we play to the
Olympians that we've won Olympians
together and you come in in the first
round
bang well that's what's happening to
Dingle Aranda right now as why how is
chasing him down well not be some hurt
feelings and what how is one of those
players that got most affected by the
pandemic that we're dealing with he was
he wasn't your fan he was taking a
little bit of a tour in Japan he's
having a great old married time before
going back and training with the seconds
in China okay and suddenly he couldn't
exit Japan he couldn't go back to China
so he couldn't actually train in person
his seconds are currently stuck in China
okay they were supposed to go to Russia
with him but they were already
quarantined and one cow said look
they've already been quarantined in
China I can't put them through that
again because they would have had to
stay in Russia quarantine for another
two weeks
Sunday he was like that's too much I'm
just gonna go solo do everything
remotely Wow but he's bringing home the
power
well that moved g5 nice after one result
expected and I was looking at the
grocery game they've made time control
but I don't see no I think Richards done
I think no advantage at all I I'm seeing
a perpetual check actually appearing on
the board and I think it's thinking if
there's more absolutely why not thinking
there's more going out of it you're no
longer can lose this game because you
have this Queen and Bishop combo chasing
a king that wants wanted security but
has none of it right now where would you
hide your King if I told you put your
King on a safe square sometimes you
you'd like to be I don't think you could
easily find that square maybe I don't
think it accepts hate I don't think it
exists
well unless my queen is sitting on d6
and I can play like King on d7 or
something that's a big any and that's
our path that's all order in this
position because your Bishop on e3 is
horrible exactly that's exactly what I
wanted to say the bishop on e3 I was
upon a PI was pushing and now I got this
position I'm very elephant I'm the
trainer of Alexandra Christian and I
know the guys gonna play the candidates
I go to whatever sage I can say please
how how do I fix this guy's time trouble
because it just costs him so much I know
he had such a wonderful position give
the guy enough time he'll converted well
what happened some complications happen
he was under a couple threats he had to
take the safe route because guess what
there are threatening to doesn't want to
blunder anything right but he also lost
his advantage he did it slipped and it
slipped precipitously probably Queen B 2
is already you're stepping right
another I don't really like the idea
trading off all four rooks because the
more the pieces come off to look at
what's remaining and what's remaining is
this really sceptic Bishop on III which
is really playing a defensive role
Maurice and a dream of mine has come
true it's like a little of fantasy
variation but it looks like it has
happened or will happen in this game
check it out guys we were talking about
white saying I'm almost drawing that's
almost a fortress right over here it
looks all tits so close that was a few
moves ago but the bishop and the pawn if
only I could give up the bishop and the
pawn for that fortress if I could say
these are kind of fantasies that we have
as players when we look at positions the
guy gave him the fantasy played h4 took
it and then he played that five saying
you can't take that I'm gonna win your
Bishop yeah except what if I do take it
you check me I move you got yours I
check you you move I take mine just a
driver dad drop this is as dead as dead
a draws you're gonna get this pins
clearly doesn't work because of f3 and
I'm not losing this forever
this is the line now it looks like nepo
has simply gifted his opponent a
straight forward fortress this should be
drawn the engines are giving advantage
to black I don't understand why but does
this engine doesn't see this is just
simply dead even and there's no way to
win this position looks like if Gary
studying and careful easy doesn't
somehow loses rook by accident after
rook takes that fight that's the only
thing you would be worried about that
after you take here there's not another
move to play in this position I don't
see what that is it looks like he should
be safe the roof doesn't look like it
possibly hang even after move like maybe
III well it just seems that he should be
able to play anything almost what am I
looking for in this common guy I do have
to correct you Maurice yes the table
base says that positions lost which one
with the 1 3 with the Panos on f3 and h4
get out
this one's lost I don't yeah if you take
on a two with Chuck get out and I don't
know it just says Made in 72 wow you got
you got me there because yes one looks
so wrong I was about to say for me the
the the culprit was you move F 2 F 3 yes
I think but what I was taught is that
after the move F 2 F 3 you you you you
get behind the yes somehow the Queen
gets behind in Zook swans yeah exactly
that's what I was taught as well because
it's why I looked it up but you leave
the pawn on f2 and you put the rook on
e3 and G 3 minutes hey that's a subtlety
you guys knew that I didn't Queen takes
with check like this position I would
have said this King looking F I would be
fine of course well yeah you can't play
King f3 so if that's the case then you
are in fact losing this is deep there's
certainly out of my knowledge base and
the database is saying that this is
actually winning so then if giri knows
that then he cannot take on f5 because
he has to play this f3 move and then
that means that neppo is playing amazing
wonderfully deep chest certainly deeper
than I suppose that's some good stuff
you know this looks so equal the rook
can go back and forth between these two
squares somehow the king can make that
penetration happen yeah that's
impressive you guys got to show me this
one well I mean the main in 72 was a
little bit hard for me but I saw them
[Laughter]
can we see the all Chinese match up to
because that is I mean for me that is
just such a huge result I mean and the
big point is this last move this was a
variation by the way that could have
happened if he had played taking bishop
takes on H for the first time if you go
back before he started this the stuff
yeah back even for well so here after
okay after after after after Bishop no
no now we can go forward Bishop da root
K to the point being that if the bishop
takes h4 and this exact moment mm-hmm
then there's a rook
h2 that's possible here okay right and
with the rook on d1 its position changes
a bit in this line the engine gives the
best move here as route g4 not rook g3
rook g4 and if you take now Knight takes
pawn takes with check which which one H
bar H pot sorry the H pawn and now
giving King e2 as the next move if he's
chief and then he has just simply Bishop
G not simply the move Bishop g3 and the
game gets out of hand because after rook
play rook h8 takes on f4 rook e8 e8 mmm
correct and now King takes on e5 rook
takes on b6 rook d4 and we're in we're
in wild country where yeah where yeah
all three results are possible but yeah
angels giving much better for black like
black pass pawns are gonna be way too
strong and they're going they're rolling
down the board and you just have your
one beep on so this is crazy crazy chess
for sure but now we have a similar type
situation on the board as he has played
rookie for sacrificing the exchange the
second time around now getting this
opportunity he's played this move rook
to g4 and saying let's get wild let's
get crazy and you don't have your
counter player on the H file so I'm just
capturing and getting a great
confirmation against your opposition
so something very similar to the line
that you you showed has just appeared on
the board he played rook g4 and inviting
takes and takes with the H pawn Wow well
here he is going straight into the line
guys with f2 f3 on the board uh well we
haven't gotten that part just yet but he
has given up his bishop okay well it's
gonna taking all the pomp he's gonna
have to take the pawn he's gonna have to
go down the line so he's making the
mistake I mean well I was actually
wondering if you can draw by keeping the
pawn in life and going like rookie 5
roots g3 okay I'm gonna turn to that
game just shortly after this my feeling
is that this is actually really good for
black I mean it just exactly it's a
visual appeal yes that's too many pawns
and it's not just that it's just that
once you see this move g5 and the fact
that the e5 pawn is mulling the fact
that rook d4 is on tap desirable this is
law school it's animal exactly so the
resistance possible that would be a huge
huge upset Wow because dealer ring comes
into this hello as you say a
pre-tournament favor and to lose with
white pieces against your country by the
way my god did you see this result and
you go back to do you take the top two
players or do you take the field yes the
two Russians have indeed and it has
indeed ended in a draw that's a big
comeback by the young man who nobody is
giving any chances whatsoever
kirilus saying you can hate if you want
to but I got here and I'm gonna make the
best of it and he did say in a quote
before this tournament he said I'm here
to win I plan to win that's that's my
goal and what else should he be thinking
second place get you nothing get you
some money but that's not what you want
you want the real dollars that you're
gonna get challenging Magnus Carlsen
what an upset it would be if he came he
would be probably the least likely
player to win one of these eventually
when I think about it he would be the
least likely in this round-robin format
to ever win right ramnik sorry
Kuryakin is probably currently the
odds-on favorite to hold that unfavorite
title so as an underdog this would be
incredible simply so we'll see he's got
a long way to go during his first game
doesn't mean that much for 30 go-arounds
and a lot of gangsters to see this one
on the other hand man after seeing that
your man said now I got no time to take
the rook yet let me play something else
goes taking the rook is dead loss so he
played the move rook to h2 Dingling
right now but he got to hang on by his
fingernails but doesn't that run into
the variation you showed us earlier rook
g3 check and G Phi and sure does yeah I
mean this is monstrous right there's
gonna be monstrous you likely to take
here take bishop taste sorry
nice hanging so no time to grab this
back whatever night move you make age 4
is on tap your part on d3 is falling I
mean it's just it's a night master it's
a complete disaster Ziegler Ren is
reeling right now seeing himself lose
the very first game of the tournament
what must this young man with wise not
clear I was white yes I just also want
to clue in our audience that we do have
you Leonard
Otis over in Russia and we're gonna come
to him out very various moments in the
show to bring us what's going on on the
ground there and hopefully even maybe
even grab a player or two we do have two
results so far two draws to draw we're
looking at the potential for two wins
for the black side both of them wow
we're gonna have a certainly a long game
between onigiri and yon upon matches we
can see the standings after two games
finished in the tournament two draws
solid one between Fabien Maxime there
was some craziness near the middle but
it eventually evolved solid solid solid
until it was eventually John Rich Jerk
is gonna be kicking himself because he
needed this half court they was playing
the lowest rated player he's playing
somebody where he had just such a
crushing position exactly and he said
where did he go what happened why did I
draw and I think you you said it very
well yourself it was the time trouble a
time trouble issue you got more time to
really think about that position Queen B
2 and he's just kind of played by hand
and he didn't seize his advantage
Maurice big news guys did happen here he
understood that he couldn't take this
pawn and he went for the other block a
the one wheel the one we all know and
love with the rook on g3 but need a
shuttle back and forth on this square if
you can get his route back to g3 there's
gonna be difficult for the King to
penetrate this is a position on the
board
Alejandro tell me now that this is the
drawer please according to the table
base if you take the a pawn because the
work on g3 does seem like it should be
comfortable enough to make it happen
yeah but there's an e4 pawn there's an
e4 pawn if you remove the pawns from h4
and a-two and you put the rook on III
okay let's just magically do that
because let's say that H pawn can't
really be held yeah
if you remove h4n a to put the rukon III
it's lost okay let's just do that let's
just which is come making move sorry I
apologize but we're just gonna make some
move so we're gonna get to the position
that you're describing is lost and we're
gonna lose H for magic as well let's go
attack quick guy and let's say we get
into this position is lost why I don't
know it's lost
it's not the maiden okay I don't know
how to break it down the way you break
it down is that rook III g3 is usually
the only safe squares very broke at some
point opponent name is actually lost
because the points already need for so
if you imagine that I sacrifice my right
that's the case okay okay and I go King
here and you're saying for at some
moment there might be a queen - yeah at
some point a queen takes works like
first of all you shouldn't go through f4
you go through d4 so you always have
that extra one tempo for example okay so
I go excuse me I go here you go here I
go here
yeah we're just putting but you go Queen
c1 something like this okay now suddenly
I can't play rook III so I have to go to
a square where I'm not defensive point
that out by the way why just want to see
so rook g3 allows the immediate King and
pawn attending and if White's King
unfortunately cannot stand in front of
the pawn right yes exactly the Kings
already on the six rank so that that was
why we couldn't play the move rook III
but then we can just chill and say okay
break me down further excellent and now
I have no idea this is a two-step and it
sounds to me like there's gonna be a
process yes so you're breaking down
White's first line of defense and
there's gonna be a second line of
defense make progress you transfer the
King to d2 how you put the quit on d3
that's the plan that's I get here c3 and
then okay never can take you're always
too slow you you know I just write and
there was a king behind and once the
King gets to be too then i right now I
can just go for Keaney to Queen d4 you
have to put the Queen on dethrone
actually it's a bridge so you get to
play king c3 very pretty sorry it Murray
and it's funny in that position go back
gonna go forward go forward I had I had
an idea but they didn't work just on a
way to lose for black no you you're
behind it go back to your variation that
you were just sitting on with the King
already in the position ooh sorry
take us forward through the three
position I don't know I got there sorry
Maurice Queen d1 yes okay anyone yeah
and then moves okay rook to e3 that's
Queen so we want to play Queen d3 right
of course and then they keep going rook
just keep shoveling King DT you can't
take very important point pawn takes
will win the game so because knowing the
pawn just promotes yes I just want to go
to a position that's funny here because
I don't
I like clarity for the audience we
sometimes GM's
get ahead of ourselves and say oh yeah
just this dis dis Etobicoke per woman an
audience is like wait yeah yeah you lost
me alright so here we said a move like
rook h3 fails maybe just Queen takes
just take it exactly and then just take
the pawn so that's an important line to
note Pontius promotes easily and and
rook III fails you take a stake as well
because of the CAPTCHA so rogue g3
yeah and now you can't play Queens and
this is a weirdest thing but we're d3 is
a well the rook is on g3 so then so then
let's fight King g1 right you take on
Jimmy but as you stand at the point this
is already as looks on this is already
this guy's gonna make all the moves no
King g1 allows us capture it's funny
because you guys like the capture and I
like that too but also well this this
takes a little time that because rook g2
you still have to break this you still
have to break him okay yes no I agree
with you now now I will absolutely take
it back and I agree that this is the way
to go yeah yeah then you just you're
gonna Queen let's check and yes so what
about and what and finally yeah if you
move the rook up it's important to know
you can't leave the King back on g2 oh
sorry the KNG you can't move the rook up
because Queen of three wins the pawn on
f2 if I'm attitude yeah right away so
that that clears all the cobwebs out
right that's important we understands
this Queen d3 maneuver Alejandro points
out is beautiful very instructive not
just for you out there in audience land
but even for GM who's never seen this
concept before really nice idea of Queen
d3 well really when you look at it you
go okay how are you gonna break White's
down and white now and whites guys is
gonna shuttle is rook back and forth and
you go oh you've got a weakness on f2
you go wait a minute I don't have a
weakness enough to I can't attack it the
king is not crossing the third-ranked
and then you go aha that's the clue
you put the Queen on d3 yes so your king
can cross the third-ranked
that's a very instructive plan
Maurice over to you I would say yeah
this game I'll take this sure before we
go on break a quick break this position
is still on the board it's somewhat
surprising that the move rook g3 Chuck
hasn't played out long a long time ago
know why he has so much time I love the
approach he's one-handed it I understand
that he has a lot of time on the call
but he played this this move Bishop
takes h4 was played before he got the
second time controller right it was his
40th move right then he got his extra
time on the clock he he got an extra
hour am i right yes 50 minutes let's go
with yes okay so so uh he spent over 13
minutes right now well thinking about
this position no I'm not I understand
it's a candidate is important but you do
want to keep a little bit of pace as
well we saw what happened to Chris chick
he had a completely dominant winning
position in our eyes and then he started
using the typical G grishnack time
technique got into pressure what is well
call thinking and I think I'm curious
what is he why is he not happy with this
move and this variation that looks so
powerful
check g5 looks so straightforward I was
thinking rook d4 g5 first okay also good
also good but I mean I'd look at the
position I have to tempting options rich
III and g5 to me right and I stop and I
consider route before I think temptation
is there right I mean it's one of those
alarm bells went for a chess player how
many times have we had wonderful
positions three moves look like they win
and the truth is two of them do and one
of them doesn't how many times do we
choose sometimes it's not good to have
too much choice yes I just have a
straightforward move it works good let's
go don't worry about the others I will
tell you that you find it 2,800 you've
got three winning moves except as you
say only two of them win and you choose
real early and they crawl right out that
window that you gave them that
opportunity it's an interesting moment
in this game between the two Chinese
players because g5 like you say rook g3
and rook d4 Oliveira great look really
really fine we're going to take a short
break
and we're going to come back with more
coverage of this first and exciting
round of the 2020 candidates so we'll be
right back
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion
of open doors where people and machines
are in tune and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Lewis chess look
to start a top-tier collegiate chess
team on the very first year of the teens
inception slough obtained second best
university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back here at the first round
of the candidates tournament where we
already have two results both games
ending in a draw
certainly Christian the most upset
player out of the four a theatre huge
advantage against Crewe Alexandra but
I'm troubled by a game yet again and he
let it slip away but having said we got
two draws I think we've got two wins
that we're about to see to start this
candidates tournament as it looks like
Amish Gary has slipped himself into a
lost Queen versus rook ending yeah he's
got some pawns we were just arguing
amongst ourselves
if ami had gotten his rook to g3 in his
pawn to a3 would he have survived and
the jury finally decided we think so but
we were not sure it's the other problem
was that we didn't see a way to get
there even though that might be a draw
we didn't really find a way where you
could actually preserve the point
exactly Queen B 1 was played on the
board Oh Queen B 1 was played right King
a3 with the idea that we'll get we're
going to jettison the h4 pawn down the
line but the idea was to maintain F 2
and a 3 but I think so no but I think
here III should would okay so how many
points you don't have a fortress let's
make a move okay so km an hour of g3 oh
sorry you wanted to play III because I
want to break your fortresses okay so
you think I should play e3 at one and I
think that should win yes Wow and then I
the the rationale being that when you
get behind the pawn is the same thing
that's what we're talking about earlier
when the pawns on f3 it's a loss because
there is a way to break this okay so I
can I can have two pawns I can have a
pawn on a four and H for this is that's
definitely not a fortress that's not
good well the thing is once you have a
point of the third and not on the second
there is no creation of a fortress right
those don't exist anymore okay so what
gearing needs is that pawn and f2 and I
think if you place a three never would
have thrown in the move
III knowing
no longer is a fortress possible you
would be have to worry about a bunch of
pawns but it's a queen the Queen can
capture a power relevance that security
of that rook that's the problem and this
the rook is just not that secure
eventually you Zuzu are white of course
this will take a long time a lot of
vessels breaking it but it should be
winning okay and instead of that Giri
has gone into this positions that we had
been analyzing giving up the a to pawn
putting the rook on g3 did he start with
rook to e3 I think so okay he took on a
two okay
logical and if you lose h4 we just think
this is dead right and I don't think
anything else matters okay
after rook e3 obviously I'm looking at
this boner
yes it's Queen c2 c2 Queen d5 I don't
see why it matters again it doesn't
matter if you lose the phone it was not
an f2 it's not a fortress exactly that's
the key of the position right but
Murray's update us what happened in the
Chinese duel where we also expect what
how to convert indeed that my testicle
this is a beatdown this is just spiked
and go home you can maybe you don't have
to go home what did you gonna have to
get the heck out of here because he's
just getting rolled right now g6 after
much consideration is what whining how
played the move Knight takes g4 f j g4
who came to III Bishop to e7 to and h4
yes I'm getting to that
because h4 happened in the game and
that's all you had to see the move of h4
you just stare at those to pass pawns
you see a king landing on f5 u c g5 got
up at any moment you realize your rook
can't stop two pastors and you're saying
Lin please thank you very much
congratulations because this was a crush
what a win by wang hao dominating after
having a difficult position
we saw the moment i would go back to
this critical moment in the game when
rook d7 occurred and very impatiently
the move f4 was played we thought it was
best to get everything lined up put a
king here first get garden to this pawn
prepare such a break inside he played
out for immediately and this move is the
one that he missed that he will be
crying about he missed this f5 shot that
changed the whole complexion of the
this allowed a rook to show up on g6 his
H pawn came under heavy fire and he
ended up losing the game to his
countryman what a start
you want a surprise start that's one for
sure as Wang out has now taken the lead
in this tournament those are words you
didn't expect anybody to say he is now
in clear first but that's pending the
game between Nepal Moochie and onigiri
let's talk about one how we think about
top chess players throw all our names
like giri and VL who is one how among
them and I have to say extremely
dangerous yeah that's right she doesn't
keep himself at the top ten I don't even
know if he's broken into top ten well I
read and remember him as a junior player
an extraordinary oh you know like the
way he's in the world you thought to
yourself okay this is a guy that's going
to be you know in the top ten just as
you've described it but then I think his
path went into the academic world he was
chasing his degree and he was doing seem
to me that he got pulled out of chess
and then I was really stunned when he
won and qualified he won the Isle of Man
oh man
yeah and qualified and I said well like
you just said dangerous he's in pretty
much every top player he has a great
score against a lot of them and as you
said for a few years he wasn't focused
on chassis was focusing on himself on
academia he loved video games he loved
traveling loved enjoying life okay and
is that the way from the chess world for
a bit right and it seems that the
candidates focused himself again he had
a lot of trouble preparing for this
event a look at his plane display has
been amazing today she had it release if
he starts to the game I didn't like the
way he started but then found every
single resource perfect right something
similar with Yun nepo actually somebody
like like nipple guy that got pulled
away from the world of chess always
always always a great talent and it's
interesting that the bill came back to
Murray's jump in please I'd like to say
let's not overstate this it's so
unromantic aim into this tournament
number 12 in the world
that's nothing to sneeze at these kind
of players can defeat a top player it
happens
we've seen magnets go down to even
lesser players than that and in this
game he had difficulty to me the big
story of this game is to move there
super impatient f4 or I guess they're
they're clearly two stories the
impatient f4 biding Lauren so just a
really surprising that you play a move
like that but they're missing this shot
f5 and then the incredible
resourcefulness directs play powerful
click once f5 happening found rookie six
route g6 I think even we guys will be
thinking you're in trouble man I'm gonna
put my Brooklyn g4 you're in a lot of
trouble and they need to just simply
roll his opponent it happened very fast
this is cascading which normally is what
happens psychologically you got the
position under control I got this guy
play have for this works and then you
see a five and then you see rookie six
and rook g6 and it's just like punches
to the face every move and you just go
down and this is what happened to ding
Lauren so at the moment I'm gonna say
the jury's out going out with a great
start to be sure and by the way let's
make this point when how now in first
place he is now a top ten player he's
jumped into number eight or nine in the
world and but one ding Lauren is no
longer a 2800 after this game and the
live rating list Bing Lorena slipped
just below 2800 that can't feel as a
great start for him either and as we
said this kind of format we've seen it
nine times already this being the 10th
and only one player in history has ever
lost the first round and qualified at
the end and that was McHale tall back in
1959 we're going back a long time
ding Lorraine will have to buck history
in order to pull this off 60 years of
history in fact also tournament that was
not 14 rounds recovered immediately by
the way Tom I think he went like two in
a row and then he went it on that
ridiculous 10 out of 12 streak 10 wins
and two draws also seven-and-a-half out
of eight in between that so yet Tom
sounds pretty nicely it was
fifty percent for for the for the first
five rounds yeah you got twenty eight
rounds yeah right exactly you've got
time to recover H pawn still on the
board from on each point of view Jerry's
thinking and this is important if he
keeps the H point of life by some magic
of chukka by crook yes yeah then I think
you can't win but I don't think you can
keep it alive that's a big difficulty of
the position right because I'm thinking
in a dream world from whites perspective
you get the pawn to h6 you get the rook
to h3 and your chances of draw and begin
go way up right okay this is a seven
move seven piece position right and it's
in the table bases table base somewhere
I don't have them with me exact but I
know that at your fingertips I only have
the sixth table base with me but I know
that this has been solved Oh shocked if
White's surviving this one to be honest
well we don't think so either political
season yeah sir I know yeah I know that
Alejandro wasn't born when one Jesse
Jackson was running for president right
and his famous slogan yasser was the
rainbow coalition but the three words
always good to have just like three
words although this current president
has used for him but his was keep hope
alive keepo keep hope alive and where's
hope that h pawned exactly that a spawn
for hope I already ate keep hope alive
is that h1 if you can keep that pawn
he's got chances without it though it's
gonna be tough but how can you get Zeus
wait so it's so easy to get zoomed in
this these types of positions the Queen
just laughs at the rook because it's
such a mobile piece in my comparison and
it looks like that H pawn may indeed
drop again I don't know either
in this endgame but I'm sure the table
bases and everybody running out there
you can go baseline you let us know
exactly how this could happen exactly
I'm looking at the move after Queen
takes a - by the way I'm looking at the
move
h5 immediately my Queen d5 already wins
the pawn right
exactly I was going to say that if you
go Queenie - which is basically the the
type of situation I'm hoping for yeah
that I'll be able to play h6 put my rook
on h3 and tie down one of blacks pieces
whether it be the queen or the king as
you pointed out a very nice move Queen
d5 retro because it's a dual threat
you're threatening not only to take the
pawn on h5 you've got a discovered check
with III now help me out here Alejandra
I was gonna play rook here to e3 so I'm
dealing with one threat
I would guess King f6 King f6 and now
okay look stuck so he judged I just
attacked with King g6 you still can't
defend okay but three looks lost as a
second I was trying to promote a queen I
promoted cream just the Grandmaster
camaraderie understanding here I do in
fact Queen is white but no I'm sorry to
say that two black Queens is plenty
pretty danger and it looks like I get
killed right away well okay I tried to
hold on with the H pawn she finally made
a move he's late rook h3 in the position
that we had okay and I believe that
nipple instantly played them of Queen d5
which again sets up this very nasty
threat of e4 III check and okay let's
say I drop back I want to maintain the
rook on h3 so at least I can pretend
that I'm supporting my H bar I think we
need five here just to make sure you
never even think about it while my King
is walking on the board and then you get
your king - okay okay
double-click on the board okay and there
you go so actually this is the current
position Kim G - just blade okay I think
one queen king of blonde Queen dy
Oh Queen d5 kf1 okay I just said Kim Ji
Won I think it actually would have just
transpose yeah it seems like the same
thing and so this is the current
position and now we've got probably
queen g4 chat it absolutely forces you
to play King gauge - exactly I'm with
you why don't you guys just play Queen
h5 say look so you know your king is
marching at least up I'll March up the
board to where I will then be able to
play queen g4 and zu q right exactly you
get the King on a great position and
then sooner or later you're gonna have
to move the rook away from the HP on
maybe to g4 actually I could mean maybe
put my king on g4 I'm not sure because I
always have our g3 check right yeah
right and you can't say that they were
taken because of rotation well let's go
work let's go for it let's try make some
moves we get to do it the players have
to calculate yeah so Kings you to King
up the board I'm just hanging about I'm
waiting for you to decide what you're
gonna do okay
break break it down how does white now
here if you could magically play the
move Queen f1 that's hmm that would be
nice but you but you can't play you say
d1 King g2 is gonna happen I'm a queen
d1 King G - yes no because you can't h5
right h5 is way too slow Travel loss
Queen f1 f1 yeah that's not us you're
gonna get so I can have to play King
here right let's let's play less sorry
let's just play it so the distance of
the folks you see at Queen d1 age 5 yes
Queen D 1 H 5 because we got time
so take five Queen f1 eight-six
you're very close Queen takes King back
you can and they're gonna play III yep
and spoil my party cuz now 87 you just
push one more and that's the end of that
yeah convince me that the two queens
like a major question okay what he did
take it what did he do whether he did
play queen each Friday please check
their rooms III and why did he not take
upon huh somebody somebody stronger than
me to do that okay but the table bases
will tell you if we take stage four is a
win or a draw now yeah it's Owen so it's
a hundred per unit now because of that
whole Queen D yeah I mean what can
possibly change right exactly so little
bit of a mystery here yeah me kind of
want to capture the phone right that's
the whole point I think that was the
whole point there's something so wrong
mystifying I think is the word that's
odd odd indeed yeah cuz we were
expecting King h2 because we just you
have to keep hope alive
that's I hope I hope th pawn has to stay
on the board and in this position he's
decided to leave the pawn on the board
for the moment but rook rook h3 can be
played and asked you to figure out how
to win that position that will be
stunning well you go Queen chief are
known rosy but then why is why is Gary
giving away the H pawn because the
ending is lost that's uh he might not
know it's lost well I'm you know what
I'm glad because you guys you know
showed me earlier that I didn't really
know the niceties of this ending it's
good to know that Gary may not either so
let's let's see how that works out
because he's super strong
I'm sure magnets are sitting back going
come on guys these are the exact endings
I spend all my time looking
because Magnus is the kind of guy
there's no fortress there's never a
fortress I'm gonna break you down some
kind of way and he eerily knows all
these kinds of positions that you'd
never think he would anybody would sit
and study for hours and hours
I think Magnus maybe he doesn't need
that law and be the genius that he is
he's like no I'm learning these because
we're gonna get in these positions
against the elite players and I want to
be able to crack them in that fifth six
hour of play yeah he was one of those
great players who really chiseled his
endings and as a very young player in
fact his maturity in the Indian was
really really remarkable and yeah the
fact that he has this incredible memory
also makes them I think the greatest end
game player in the world
so should this game be decisive
remarkable start guys
2 2 wins 2 draws it's noise dudes was
black that changes the character of the
situation right a lot of the players
coming in with their great preparation
was white
especially Gary Gary proposes let's
sharpen it up let's go I'm gonna
sacrifice a material look at all these
cool ideas I had Queen B one rook takes
a just haven't I'm gonna make Nippon
Miyagi right careful suddenly it all
backfires it does he makes a couple of
indecisive moves Queen d3 for example
it's not only neppo
he sees his chance p-51 boom boom boom
and then he sees [ __ ] Bishop takes
it for King chief of King g7 and then on
top of that you must know he still
probably draws that rook and Bishop and
game couldn't coordinated himself yeah
and it wasn't force that he had to give
up his queen by the way because also a
remarkable decision at that point it
seemed that he was running out of
options
okay so that was a done deal too so
again we're talking about earlier in
this game everybody write about the
these parts right here is where on each
decided that after the move rook b8 it
was sensible to give up his queen for a
rook and a bishop and to try to make
this position a draw well as things
unwound it
turned out that this bishop got
sacrificed for a number of ponds and
again uh nish was on the back foot and
from this position they've reached this
ending which we think is a win maurice
over to you and if we have to talk about
the game of the round so far period
I'm a who's gonna give it the game of
the right to me it's this one right the
one that you guys were looking at right
there the one between the from the cheat
and Geary yes this was a super important
game yes is a decisive game yes why now
played brilliantly once he got into
trouble and it was the this position
make another move for black and white is
still doing well I mean you you argued
that earlier
Alejandro maybe off air make another
move for black guys and wife's doing
well I get it
I just got everything yeah this end game
is only winning with the King on g2 if
the King transfers to eat too you can't
possibly break it down okay we're gonna
come back to onigiri that's why he's not
taking all right let me finish my point
I'll come in a second so this this game
really hinged on this moment and after
f5 okay was straightforward demolition
after rookies sakes work g6 and even
here remember we have this waste period
of time after root d1 where he played
rook d4 and in the middle of it he just
he just got to move 40 before he finally
took on h4 so what does he play that
five it was only like 10 moves just
whoop and you were gone right it was a
horrible move f4 a big miss assessment
that caused him to go on tilt afterwards
and his position just simply and
collapsed so kudos to Wang out this game
though by the way has this other game as
you're describing that this one with a
with a king on e2 changes the complexion
completely now this one has everything
what a game layers on layers and layers
of opening prep followed by a deep
response brilliant play with b5 and
craziness the exchange sacrifice now
this wild ending now in it you're
pointing out technical issues on the
part on h4 if the King gets the e2 I
mean this game has all the stories it's
and we know now that you said that we
don't even know what the finish line is
going to be because of that incredible
resource as you pointed out Alejandra
makes a ton of sense if this King gets
to hear a different kind it's similar to
the other fortress or this point over
here interesting point now now what now
how does black win the game and that's
why Napa hasn't taken on an age for that
says he realizes that if the King gets
to e2 and that's what happens for
example the move rook a3 is currently on
the board this position right after
Queen g4 route g3 Queen takes h4 it's
just I don't know if it's a blunder I
don't know this positions winning or not
when takes age fourteen f1 and the idea
is that with the king on e - and your
shuttle back and forth you're not
allowing that bridge of the Queen yeah
so this as we try to puzzle this out
let's go to Russia and go to Leonard
otice who has some updates from welcome
guys I just went yeah hey good morning
it's like 9 p.m. over here in in the
middle of Russia good evening
yeah thanks thanks it's it's an
historical event I've been traveling so
much in the past two three years or the
green Chester offense although all the
other top events and this is so weird
I've been in the playing hole alone with
the eight candidates and to our Peters
no spectators no press allowed after
five minutes Sasha Gray shook during his
press conference he said that like he
followed all the other three games very
closely because he has nothing else to
do during the game and and and yeah this
whole coronavirus thing it makes it's so
weird
and I'm so happy to be part of it
I notice Leonard that at the opening
ceremony somebody didn't get the memo
no congregation of 50 persons because
there was a thousand people in the
theater yeah so most of the people who
were there in the theater they also
played the Karpov cup they were like a
series of extra events next to the
candidates plant and they were named
after Anatoly Karpov and so there was
like this huge open tournaments with
like hundreds and hundreds of players
and they all attended the closing and
opening ceremony as well and when the
players were asked if they wanted to
join the opening ceremony basically
nobody really was eager to who come so
we had an opening ceremony without any
players sponsors were there accreditor
field president was there I had to be
there as well to take photos and the
opening ceremony was wonderful it was
like a dance performance a lot of music
and I really enjoyed it if it was safe
I'm not so sure we get like medical
tests twice a day they check if I have a
temperature they check my throat's so
far everything has been good I also got
a coronavirus test and I think everybody
is negative so that's a good thing but
yeah I hope this opening ceremony was
not destructive in any way wow what a
situation it's changed so much and the
players they've also expressed their
concerns yes of course we had tell us a
bit about the controversy of timur raja
baath stepping out of the tournament
because of his fear is about coronavirus
70 days response and we're yeah so of
course I did not talk to our team or at
all so like oh I know is what is written
in the press but like he he was very
early with expressing his concerns
regarding the coronavirus and maybe the
popular opinion was not in his favor
back then if you had waited
few more days when other sports events
were already canceled may be deferred
act of fee they might have been
different and the teamwork was like yeah
I really don't want to play and in the
circumstances and he didn't really trust
the measurements or the measures that
that fit I was planning to do so he
decided to step out of out of the
candidates but it was like very early on
like must be like more than 1/2 week or
2 weeks ago because he's dead it was
March 6th right to reply definitively is
he playing or is he not playing
yes it's 11 days ago yeah definitely
yeah if he had waited maybe four more
days or notice what would have happened
with the candidates but now they invited
and feel and it would be very stressful
for the whole trip cycle to postpone or
cancel this tournament because then you
have nine candidates right now
ding Lehren in order to avoid the
quarantine coming from China had
actually gone to Russia early and been
quarantine for two weeks and I assume he
had a fine experience nothing happened
to him yeah so like he's here together
with a coach and a delegation leader of
the Chinese Federation his parents are
usually traveling with him they are not
here he has no other seconds here but
yeah he he has been the curtain he knew
what he was what he had to do and and he
arrived in in Russia in time right now
no not a single foreigner is allowed to
get into Russia they've long been the
country yeah exactly so even if you
folks like to come to 303 in work it's
it's impossible I actually hope that I
would be able to fly out of the country
to some place on April 5th but yeah
that's for later concern and the wave
like a Spanish journalist Nasser Garcia
and he arrived from Spain I would say
like four or five days ago
and it was already packed underwear
measures for Spanish residents getting
into Russia so he's in a curtain in a
hotel like two kilometers away from from
us and he will be released in in ten
days Wow
that changes the dynamic of so many
things it's not just psychologically
it's difficult to your focus on the
tournament right just imagine Fabiano
Caruana his parents are currently in
Spain they are elderly yes they're
exactly the difficult demographic and
right in the middle of everything
they're currently in a city they live
just outside Madrid that's in a complete
lockdown situation how do you focus I
understand Leonard one last question for
you before we let you go
I mean Sasha Grichuk always a great
interview absolutely when Hal in the
press conference did when he'll go to a
press conference yes he it went there on
his own thing leerin decided not to not
to join a press conference I have to
admit that I was preparing for this
interview during his press conference
that I miss everything of it no problem
just was a curious if he if he had a
finger on a critical moment or not but
that's ok we'll we'll pick out I don't
have any information about three Leonard
thank you for joining us keep in touch
let us know what's going on if any
breaking news we appreciate your
sacrifice into Russia in these difficult
times thank you it's looking forward to
seeing you my friend
yeah always love traveling with you
we'll we'll get back to it at some point
for sure absolutely now solve the
problem for us I just want to go because
I thought you would check the table base
sir
Alejandro Ramirez Gianna so you have a
table base back here I decided let me
check it myself and in this position it
does show definitively the only move to
draw a king of one and it does indeed
raw this is a done deal you cannot take
on h4 because king of one and you
proceeded to create the blockade on the
e2 square and
just simply drawn that is the dynamic
these guys are good that good indeed
knowing all these nuances and
differences and that is the dynamic
neppo face and that's why giri allowed
that position because he knows all the
possibilities here and so a new position
has arisen on the board if we can just
get to it and here the King is on the f4
square but boy how are the H pawn is
saying or I guess hope the H pawn is
what we're calling it now as you can
keep this H pawn alive this rule can
always go to e3 if you try one of those
funny business and because the H point
is always threatening to go down the
board it's four moves away so this King
on the other side that was just winning
easily earlier doesn't do the same
anymore because the H pawn will simply
rush race to the bank rank and the king
will have to go the other way instead of
just cleaning this pawn so no easy queen
sacrifices is what aneasha saying and
this game suddenly is very rich was
about to say if the game was adjourned
like in my old days we would have
discovered that we can't allow the King
to e2 but the point is these players are
playing through there's no adjournments
here and this is remarkable insight by
Yan this is really really impressive
like there was an old fogies tournament
recently in holland for top players Yan
Tim on Anatoly Karpov Robert Huebner
project Nikolas Youth one nickel each
won the event but Anatoly said that you
know he felt that the older generation
played and games better thanks to the
adjournment and the fact that the
players have to play through and they're
tired and sometimes they make and game
slips it would have been an easy easy
slip to play Queen takes h4 I mean
everybody would play Queen takes h4 and
after King f1 discover to your horror
and this is this is really good stuff a
very current position yes it will boil
down can I win the h-bomb or can't
when the h1 without allowing that he
needs to move to everyone so this is the
question that we have the challenge is
it possible for black to pick up this
guy without allowing the king to
everyone
ideally you take it with the king
currently of course since here is
keeping that rook on three
I know g5 you can't actually make
progress on the G file right Black's
King is not going over here and munching
go ahead yeah yeah so we need a plan
okay so let's just fight okay by the way
you can't lose a foot that's also
important exactly oh yeah yeah right we
must maintain the pawn on e4 so I've got
Queen e2 and say oh you're in suits on
okay about here there's no problem we're
talking about the rookie three move
right so no rook g5 because of III right
and okay so now you have to go rook III
and the whole point is after check you
still can't take the pawn because of
king of one right takes on g3 603 King
III - oh sorry just to check that out
right this kind of end games don't
actually win because the pawn is just
not enough
exactly yeah kind of positions you can
get the King to e2
and that's it yeah so that's that's an
easy drop but it's important to know
this - because you will see a lot of
them when we do calculations which ones
are winning and which ones are not
winning exactly so we go back to this
moment for just a moment and I go
instead of check okay I'll go back to h5
by the way this is the point I was
making
we made this generalize point now you
can show it specifically the idea of
Queen takes III years right
so Queen takes now there was no I always
won when there was no H pawn on the
board
exactly now it turns out that this H
pawn Queens before yours there's just a
draw and we just make a an easy draw
with Queen versus Queen yeah not even
not even close so this this H pawn
staying on the board makes a huge
difference to what normally would just
be a simple winning endgame now you got
the problem the H pawn if you can't take
the h1 or lot of the blockade and you
can't take the rook and a lot of the H
pawn
fly then what how do you win what's the
plan so is there a way what is our plan
to pick this guy up okay so let me go
here okay I'll play room T 3 so the key
is to take the pawn under the conditions
where the king can I go to f1 exactly
now you can't even play king e5 because
of rook g5 check that is clear okay I'm
thinking I'll go what have I really
accomplished by getting my Queen to d1
instead of h5 nothing you just returned
all you did was repeat the position
right so supposing it was white to move
here well work III yep there's no
because rookie three you still don't
have King g4 I'll take on e4 and we know
that's a draw
exactly okay how about I start with a
move like Queen d5 in 1804 I wanted you
to play rook e3 so I could go King chief
I thought I was being clever by the way
I wanted you to allow this now I'm in
trouble losing that pawn right right the
King f1 and if I have to play Queen d1
as a compilation thing okay I gotta
believe that this my queen yeah should
be able to force a kind of a zukes walk
okay if if I provoke the pawn to go to
h5 like yeah you don't play h5 you just
go rookie three yeah maybe put it on the
wall oh thank you thank you nice very
good so now the pawn is defended rook
III is met by king g4 and oops there
goes the H there goes the blockade setup
that you want it we think we feel like
it's over right I mean now I
the king the King can't move too because
clean f1 will always be winning exactly
it just breaks that blockade totally
okay let me do let me just refresh my
board because a couple of moves have
happened it doesn't side oh sorry I
clicked the wrong game I apologize
everybody and there is the current
position with white team right the last
move was Queen d2 not Queen d1 check and
Queen B one but Queen d2 okay in this
position with Queen B one is pretty it's
pretty important let's try to defend
this one because I think there's no
other there might be some other tries
but King g2 here looks like and Queen
and we'll get here somehow right it
doesn't matter how we got here right
question is can we find a move here for
white exactly
now we think any King move that allows
Queen f1 that's that's killing close to
you for me and that's question well
we're kind of hoping that the weakness
of the ball because the thing is when I
take an H five you don't have King f1
right right below he's not gonna give my
pride is not to give you this pawn oh
but you can just put it on h6 and how
are you gonna take it as soon as you
take it with the Queen up taking
everyone right and is done once the pot
reaches age six it's a drop I can't take
your eyes that's right so to be clear
everybody what Alejandra is saying once
why it's achieved this now white doesn't
even kid care about the fam the pond
he'll just bring his King back and
achieve what we now know is it visible
with a King on e - and the pawn on f2
the rook just shuttles back and forth
and there is no bridge and it showed
earlier and in fact by the way I'll
argue I didn't have to give you the
phone I could play rook age three but
once the part is all the way down I've
leveraged three you have zero way to
make progress yeah what's the part
reaches h6s third row right so the
torrent and so everything is
there and guess what that bah five that
means right now that's about to say that
means right now why can't you just play
h5h was just a drop why isn't h5 h6 just
a drug given what all that we're saying
right now why can't you just push blows
maybe to us on the position yeah no dude
this is the current position on the
board
no can say due to what Kings on g2 right
now that was a new move
yeah and now we're wondering can white
just play so King g2 was played oh5
walks into Queen D 1 shot h5 that's
right that's what we're saying this yes
thank you that's exactly what we're
saying so you have to deal with this
because this pawn is just gonna race
once it reaches age 6 not a very far
race we know it's a drum right yep
because the Queen can't get back to d1
geometrically 6 that's the critical
point the Queen's on h5 then it can play
Queen d1 and not allow the king the
white came to get to that beautiful e 2
square but as long as it's on 86 you
cannot do it with your Queen your kings
in the way unless you can get your King
out of your King has to be on d4 then
but then how do you make progress well
because of the the movie h5 is a threat
he's played he's played Queen d1 here I
have to stop h5 he had to all right now
we need a move for white and rook g3
seems like a move because you don't have
King g4 right so because we were
thinking that we need to keep the pawn
on e4 that this is this is a this is
easy to 0 right so rookie 3 is the move
that I kind of expect and then we were
thinking that in case you black can
always pick up the pot on h4 and no
Jimmy at the cost of allowing the King
either to e1 or e2 exactly do I have a
better move after rookie 3 rookie 3
played by the way only more so the
question is this will be one of the
great escapes that I've seen we just
understood that's the key amazing as the
key
remember I was saying this was a fantasy
of mine and then you guys showed that
the position with the pawn on f3 was was
not correct right but the fantasy was
deal like give up your bishop and then
have just this fight right but you have
to know the particulars it's good to
know I have the fantasy and the dream
that I had but you also have to have the
specifics as well to buttress the ideas
and Geary simply got it he said no I
understand
what I'm aiming for I know yes I'm going
to give up the bishop I'm gonna create
this kind of position and guess what
it's a draw the richness here as we
analyze further and further in dig it's
showing just how remarkable this young
man's knowledge is and depth and insight
and also why it was really hard to beat
him in that last candidate she was the
partner and he drew all his games which
is hard to do but he managed to pull it
off because Geary is not a tough out
you're gonna have to beat him and he's
proving here why it is so difficult you
get that big an advantage I think that
neppo will see this he'll be bitter
afterwards you'll see come on
I had this one somehow some way I should
have won it but it's proving to be next
to impossible now that we see that the H
pawn is the force that changes
everything about this position and
sometimes you have that feeling that you
missed it you had it and you missed it
I'm not sure and it might just never
been there right there's a lot we had to
go back to pretty good getting this out
of that position exactly I mean what
else can you really expect you can't
hold on to the F pawn right right yeah
Queen versus rook and a bishop but you
know you have this majority you end up
this is good as it gets
exactly we gave it go back you you you
win the bishop for a pawn or two like
I'm game man you think I get rid of the
g3 pawn right and I put it on h4 which
is strike excellent range weakens yeah
probably will die at some point yeah but
here black is thinking I get to win the
bishop
I get to win the a to pawn for my F
point only for the f6 pawn
oh no by the way I'll move the g3 pawn
to h4 which is in my favor
if I leave the pawn on g3 it's an
obvious draw yeah exactly
so black does you know the maximum that
he can achieve there no there's a queen
of five here that was possible where I
keep the fight alive right here we see
three looked like a great move because
of everything that he accomplished but
Queen at five keeping the fight alive
with everything on the board was also
very rich not clear that you can deal
with this this other plan of keeping but
okay why not rogue d2 or something like
this we need 225 yeah Queen I 582 okay
sorry just second Queen f5 rook d2 as I
suggested I like a lowly human
actually even even here there's a
possibility of h4 immediately keeping
the Queen on a quick Queen keeping the
dynamics alive
but I take on h4 it right and then queen
up for and I go I mean I'm just thinking
on a good day you'll win your f pawn for
my bishop on do you wanna my God willing
not expand for the bishop is what you're
saying I went to f6 pawn and f3 exactly
that's a different pawn that's right
that's a very different part Wow
fighting that pawn is gonna be beasty
nice can we keep going because I mean I
am going to lose because I'm playing an
engine right rooty - okay yeah because
this was a very intriguing line h4 h4 I
take we're not for rookie to rookie -
and Maurice is saying look I'm gonna
march with this pawn from f5 to f3 I'm
gonna give you a checkmate and I don't
think he's wrong h5 okay you're saying
you're not you're gonna make it very
difficult for me to play I wanna make it
difficult for you to make that move - so
so so you want me to take this guy for
example this kind of positions right you
go King e1 I'm gonna start threatening
this it takes e4 and a3
I'm just not sure I'm actually should
take C for instead of kingi what was the
problem with that what we're trying to
achieve Bishop takes e4 you can't check
me me yeah and then rookie no not rookie
through because Queen d1 actually that's
fine rookie three Queen they were kings
you two I put the pot on a 3 and we know
yeah just what we wanted but also you
were suggesting that if you could just
open here you might get here I have some
problems because the king is in a very
bad position Queen right and this looks
Wow but I guys let's just go back to the
real game but that's I still think that
was well within Garry Marshall yeah Wow
I've got it I mean I'm gonna be very
very curious after the game if on each
actually had it only knew that this was
a draw with a pawn on h4
or if he just figured it out kind of
hard to know this right exactly
I will 100 basic and exactly I'm just
kind of thinking I'm kind of proud of
ourselves that we broke down just the f2
vs e for yeah patting myself on the back
not quite finished but this is
remarkable and by the way even that
Indian that you talked about the pot on
a3 is different from the pond at age 4
yes but we didn't think that would the
Queen d3 not being available anymore
because of the pawn on 8th yeah there's
no king d - I can take the Queen let me
go back to explain everybody what we're
just talking about here actually soon as
you cross I can play a for what we were
thinking is that after move like this if
black had gotten gone for this type of a
situation and assuming the king doesn't
get two years just a lot of assumptions
yeah we've got to make these assumptions
that we were say let's say here so with
the pawn on a3 what that meant was that
the King simply could not cross any more
- with Queen d3 see now we're hoping
that the king could go here the king
could go here and eventually target the
h2 upon the
fact that the pawn is on a three means
that we can do we take right away I
think you have to wait you cannot take
you wait for the King to be on deep - I
don't think it works any other way so we
go here here here here
I think they wait on g3 but let's say
that you get to this was okay and here
now I have to take and go hey father no
I don't know that doesn't work hold on
you guys may know can I see something
yes back here King on d4 here if I say
Sony 3 yeah yeah you probably I want to
wait on g3 with the rook you I don't
think you can wait with you three here
let's show that that you can take on e3
in this position ok so if I go King g1 I
can take on e3 in this position and
because I just take and I'm screening
with check is the second even if you
think win with Jack I think you're too
fast no no don't do that
oh sorry that was a mouse lit now king
d2 Zant do and this is a win because the
pawn actually Queens with Chuck with
Chad it's important that you clean
mature it is actually but you were
saying that what you've got to do is
hang out with the rook on the g3 square
yeah so that when they can cross just
chill rookie three root G three rookie
three reach III as long as you're King
Sanji - I think you're okay I think
because what's your progress I played
rookie 3 route g3 and if you take on e3
with the past a fun oh yeah that is a
drug then your one tempo behind the
Kings on g2 so anytime you go here I go
here and now this is a drum please
because I'm sure some people are
wondering okay sorry rook g3 Kingi to
rook III check Queen takes pawn takes
yeah and you don't get to Queen and
you're behind your behind is white
because you're on the fourth
yeah and blocks already on the fifth the
problem is that the king is in front of
this pawn and not just racing there on
the board so now you equalize by being
on your fifth he's on his fifth or she's
on her fifth and in any rate
simultaneously there's no funny business
that's there's no checkmate with the
Ponte three it's a draw
exact we're not guaranteeing anything no
but anything right we think it's a draw
yeah yeah which means that it seems like
a draw but it might have been a draw all
along that's crazy that Bishop takes e4
at a certain moment Wow okay well I was
saying
Anisha is anisha's Queen sacrifice was
brilliant I mean wow no seriously this
is great stuff guys hang on like a
champion I know this is why these guys
are the candidates I mean that is simply
fantastic see what I saw this position I
thought the edge pawn is irrelevant
they'll win it right I didn't realize
that when you win it you lose such a
critical square that's right ah the King
to come over that was very instructive
we love her we're up to date with the
current position one of the great things
yes please one of the great things about
being a commentator is you always have a
chance to learn something that's not
like you're right in the front seat like
what more could I want then to be here
with grandmasters Alejandro Ramirez and
zero on looking at the greatest
tournament in the world and being able
to analyze positions know intimately I
thought I knew and then I was like well
I didn't know this at all yeah all those
nuances and then after everything's done
for crystal clarity yes and then I get
to get go back to my room and say what
does a nice day yeah it's amazing
I always thought that no matter how
badly I teach this job
I mean I've learned a lot like this but
today Wow for for a technical position
I'm standing how the depth of this
position by the way
remind everybody again and what the time
control time which was a hundred minutes
for the first 40 moves got it then you
get another 50 minutes on 140 okay then
you get another 15 minutes on move six
weeks we are right now where I move 62
right or 67 sorry which means he's
already gotten his next four 15 minutes
right and every move that you complete
by pressing the clock I need this I
think he went the you get 30 seconds
what house if he were in the park did he
win the ball well he brought his we got
okay
hold on guys all right okay let's keep
with the King on F 1 and G 2 well he
right here he's not played the move rook
H 3 and now we're going for because it's
a little confusing but now we're going
forward yeah right
and now I'm saying but what before rook
H 3 when the king was gonna have 6 did I
have no move here that's what Yun was
saying that I've got you in Zuke's well
no but I can play rook III I need a
target the pony because you don't have
king g6 right take on e4 thank you
that's that's no this is the f3 very
good position but is this with the edge
point yep yeah I think that this is a
win I think so this was you got the
table base dude yeah no you need to find
a seventh move okay what he did do
however is he did allow the King to
gobble the pawn and he's played the move
rook g3 in he's saying hey I've got your
king cut but wait a minute
so this was a huge blunder or difficulty
why there must be a better deal okay so
rookie three why did he reject rookie
three we've been Loudon the players and
suddenly not what King G what do you
mean King g6 like a g6 I guess he didn't
want to take on you for no it's a it's a
loss you house it a loss
I can play h5 for example I have options
for the Queen quick what do you mean in
this in you just took it
what do you mean right like a g6 h5 on
it to play but you think with a queen
you don't think with the king
rook takes e4 King f3 and then I'll
manage my and this is what we've been
discussing everybody discuss when we get
this situation we provoke the move F and
this is lost no this is not a fortress
position yes you take with the Queen
revelation just like I get it now I lost
this is so confusing I'm so it's lost
now let's be clear now we can say
because I have a table base in front of
me there is no doubt Geary is currently
losing against the omnifam yah-tchi
this is a table base made in 25 no
questions asked
okay the previous one we have to
actually figure it out with the seventh
table based which I don't have right so
for Eric house what I can tell us the
truth what a confusing endgame I thought
it was a draw then he plays King f6 and
ice magically shifts and then magically
chef I I thought he got six was just to
move right there mother some way to deal
with this yeah so like yawn we got stuck
right here and we were kind of
convincing ourselves so that on each had
brilliantly created a fortress and Yan
said well I can break the fortress by
bringing my King back that's crazy
and threatening after rookie three to go
King g6 and as it turns out he ends up
winning the pawn and now we get the
whole Queen d3 in here's gonna have to
let the King back in exactly now we get
the yang game that we saw like three
hours ago
where you put the Queen on d3 and you
penetrate which is actually a brilliant
game when I said this was the game of
the round it had now it's added even
more
it's got Grand Master's the world over
going what yeah
wait a minute wait how did he just do
that trickery that magic was
prestidigitation somehow someway he
figured out how to zoom on the guy
absolutely incredible game what a
terrific fight pineapple I mean we
learned so much and we still there's
more to learn sometimes people say well
you're ready a grandmaster what's there
left to learn you have no idea
this game is so rich it's an ocean of
possibilities and we're still gonna be
digging on this one seeing what was the
subtlety here what were the nuances
break out the table bases because this
is just so complex to try to understand
in human terms and you got three GM's in
the room so don't know how did they do
that
that was really mysterious so Maurice
let's just ask the engine because the
engines usually they're not very strong
but after the move King f6 this is this
is the point this is the key point in my
view you want this one right here yeah
yeah how do I hold this position and by
the way the engines giving an evaluation
that's off the scale right now 23 that's
done that's done it's done that's not
like maybe I'm a bad engine that's you
are dead I can see that now 23 is just
too big when you're in still under the
nine points maybe seven maybe it's
season five it sees that it's gonna be
up material because it's got a queen
this position is - 23 - 23 is what I saw
okay now it's you know as I was talking
back to five I want to play this one out
yeah this is where I think Geary loses
the game which which one position it's
just an opinion right now right are you
talking about this position after rook
h3 plays rook h3 King Jesus basically
it's gone well and the back the engines
now our way over again back over 25 but
tricked me before okay sure let's not
write a cage three let's play okay can I
play the rook anywhere else and doesn't
matter
can i play like rook a3 so I have an
answer to king g6
rook a3 not rook III and rook takes e4
but rook a 4 when you play King g6
and it's just that I just don't see it
can't get the King back therefore I just
don't see how to get my king to have
where I need it right right now we see
that on the right the actual game
position on the right of your screen
abouts the net and now we're gonna see
the magical Queen d3 move that we
learned a long time ago Alejandro
pointed out I'm going to get a story
associated with this idea it was funny
we had a very I saw a very very similar
endgame between a Hikaru Nakamura and an
amateur player yes in the Probus cup of
the London chest classic by the way
sorry the move has been playing let's
not just let that pass Queen the move
Queen d3 is indeed on the board
beautiful look at that on the board now
showing that nipple completely
understood this is the way to win and
he's teaching the world and those of us
who were grizzled grandmasters who
thought we knew better this one here and
it's done gary has run after this movie
was found what a game finish what a way
to start the candidate job finish your
story with the bids so where the probe
is Cup right basically this hand game
that we have on the board Queen and pawn
against rook and fun right and Hikaru
really really wanted to sacrifice that
Queen from the room he was playing
against another strong grandmaster also
an amateur player and the amateur player
kept giving key carros partner the
option of taking on e3 or winning the
Pacific in this kind of tandem chess
you're not allowed to confirm you're not
like a sponsored car right you know
you're teamed up with a sponsor and your
sponsor teammate doesn't want to
sacrifice well hikaru luckily for him
his opponent at some point did blunder
the fool that one is good that was good
I remember an interview with Garry
Kasparov where Garry Kasparov was
actually praising somebody and saying
that their play was full of content look
at today's game this game yes of content
they're flashy brilliance ease people
might say oh a nice lady
sacrifice apiece you check checkmate ooh
that was beautiful you might even
sacrifice your queen and and and then a
picture s made in 23 moves but not full
of content brilliant sparkling like a
diamond but the games that have the
stories this happened then this happened
and another thing happened and oh is he
really winning I think it's a draw
wait a second I don't think so could we
go confirm the table base well let's
come back how did he get his King over
and and at the end there's a queen
sacrifice anyway that wins the game I
mean this one had so many stories
absolutely an amazing game to start off
for easier candidates twisted to
victories with the black pieces flung
foul from China and Janna Komachi from
Russia are the first Victor's of this
candidates round one early leaders what
a game we saw between honesty really
honorable yeah everything reparation
craziness week Kings long end game of
fortress that had to be broken down what
a story
I'm actually gonna go back since I go
out of my house I'm gonna go back and be
like where did Geary lose it where was
the actual losing move and the b5 that
visual move that yarn came up with as an
answer to Queen d3 this is an amazing
game what a start
Maurice this is the candidates this is
the game candidates and tomorrow we have
more fireworks for you Fabiano Corona
will get his shot with the white pieces
against Tyrael Alex & Co by far the
biggest rating discrepancy in the entire
tournament 150 rating points between
them I'm [ __ ] over the white pieces
will definitely be under pressure to win
this one yeah I'm napalm you actually
will be white against its compatriot
Alexandra Christian meanwhile one how
Victor of today will be facing against
the loser of that epic game on each year
with the black pieces
Maxine Bashar my graph will be right
against dangler Eddie was gonna have to
pick himself back up after losing to his
home page
guys out of words what a great great way
to start the candidate no question
Maurice final thoughts of day ones
reaction well you know I may sometimes
be accused of hyperbole but this folks
given the conditions we're living in and
these times may indeed be the greatest
show on earth everybody is watching this
as all sporting events have been
canceled but this one the candidates and
wow what a way to start
we saw some thrilling games we
definitely saw a dramatic upset in the
countrymen playing against each other
imagined teammates gold medal
compatriots but they are too fighting to
the death and of course this brilliant
game by Yann nippon-ichi absolutely full
of contents great story what a start
that's just round one we've got 13 more
to go well you've got nothing better to
do
we've got nothing better to do we're
gonna hold up and watch this incredible
show looking forward to it
see you tomorrow guys Thank You Maurice
that's the way I feel to thank you
everybody for sharing your day with us
we'll look forward to tomorrow's action
same time same channel for round two of
the candidates have a good day have a
good one thank you guys
[Music]